Oh, Bryce is fancy. He wants everyone to know it. As soon as Bryce said that, I was like, here we go. Zach's about to take him down a bit. Stepanov is very good at building a theory, but also remaining pretty close to how computers actually work. You know, Rust took the problem with writing code in C++. Hey, that's enough, baby. I'm sorry, but I mean, I was just answering what you asked me,
哦，布莱斯真讲究。他想让每个人都知道。布莱斯刚说完那话，我就觉得，得嘞，好戏开场了。扎克要稍微杀杀他的威风了。斯捷帕诺夫非常擅长构建理论，同时也非常贴近计算机的实际运作方式。你知道的，Rust 解决了用 C++ 编写代码时的问题。嘿，够了，宝贝。抱歉，我的意思是，我只是在回答你刚才的问题，
and I don't think you should call me babe. A good review of high-level design and a good design of a library are isomorphic in that you want lots of things to be the same about them. If it's possible to do so, you want to make it impossible to use it incorrectly. If that's not possible, you want to make it difficult to use it incorrectly. Ah, damn. Shit's popping. I like how that just doesn't sound like it goes with hosted by Bryce and Connor. Welcome to ADSP the podcast episode 161 recorded on December 18th, 2023. My name is Connor and today with my co-host Bryce, we are joined by Zach Lane for our fourth holiday special, a special episode, our longest yet, all released
而且我觉得你不该叫我宝贝。高层设计的良好评估与库的良好设计是同构的，因为你希望它们有很多相似之处。如果可能的话，你想做到让人不可能错误地使用它。如果那不可能，你想让人很难错误地使用它。啊，该死。太劲爆了。我喜欢这种听起来就不像是布莱斯和康纳主持的节目的风格。欢迎来到 ADSP 播客第 161 期，录制于 2023 年 12 月 18 日。我是康纳，今天和我共同主持的搭档是布莱斯，我们迎来了扎克·莱恩，这是我们的第四个节日特别节目，一期特别节目，也是我们历来最长的一期，全部都
in one cut. In today's episode, we talk about a plethora of topics, including the elements of programming, the Rust programming language, the Hylo programming language, C++, 20, 23, 26, 29, all of the upcoming features that people are excited about, and a lot more. We hope you enjoy today's special episode. Should we switch to a different Google? No, this is perfect. Also, should I be recording right now?
一次性剪辑发布。在今天的节目中，我们讨论了大量的主题，包括编程元素、Rust 编程语言、Hylo 编程语言、C++ 20、23、26、29，所有人们期待的即将推出的特性，以及更多内容。希望大家喜欢今天的特别节目。我们要换到另一个谷歌账号吗？不，这完美极了。还有，我现在应该在录音吗？
Should I be recording right now? Yes, just for the viewer right now, what we are seeing of Connor is we are seeing a black and white image that looks like it's nighttime. And it's flickering at about, I would say, like 80 hertz at least. It is. It's a little terrifying. Yeah, it looks like a horror movie. It really does. It looks like one of these cheap Blumhouse movies like Paranormal Activity or something. It's like the black and white grainy one light source night vision thing.
我现在应该在录音吗？是的，仅就目前的观众而言，我们看到的康纳的画面是一个黑白图像，看起来像是深夜。而且它在以大约，我想说，至少 80 赫兹的频率闪烁。确实如此。有点吓人。是的，看起来像恐怖电影。真的。它看起来就像那种廉价的布伦豪斯电影，比如《灵动：鬼影实录》或者别的什么。就像那种黑白、带有颗粒感、单一光源的夜视风格。
It's just all creepy. You know, the really bad part here is Connor's reason for why this is happening. Oh, no. I was talking about you, Bryce. Oh, no. Connor's weird, too. Are you also in a working kitchen? He's in an airport lounge.
简直阴森透了。你知道，这里真正糟糕的部分是康纳对为什么会这样的解释。哦，不。我刚才说的是你，布莱斯。哦，不。康纳也很奇怪。你也是在一个工作的厨房里吗？他在机场休息室。
He's using Linux. And does your laptop have an NVIDIA GPU? It does, yes. Yes, this is entirely our fault. I mean, the thing is, though, and I've just realized that this Wi-Fi quality is not great, so I'm going to be dropping in and out of this call. So I can't slack off today. I've got to carry this recording. Which I can't slack off today. I gotta carry this recording.
他在用 Linux。你的笔记本电脑有 NVIDIA GPU 吗？有的，是的。是的，这全都是我们的错。我的意思是，问题在于，我刚刚意识到这个 Wi-Fi 质量不太好，所以我等下可能会断断续续地掉线。所以我今天不能偷懒。我得撑起这次录音。我今天不能偷懒。我得撑起这次录音。
Which airport lounge are you in and at which airport? I'm in San Diego in the Aspire Lounge in Terminal 2. I don't know if I've ever been there. Yeah, maybe this was a bad idea in hindsight. Before we informally introduce Zach, should I just... I've turned my camera up. Is that the best option at this point?
你在哪个机场休息室，在哪个机场？我在圣迭戈，在 2 号航站楼的 Aspire 休息室。我不知道我有没有去过那里。是的，事后看来这可能不是个好主意。在我们正式介绍扎克之前，我是不是应该……我已经把摄像头调亮了。目前这是最佳选择吗？
I won't be able to keep us... It's super freaky. Alrighty. I mean, this probably all ended up in the episode, so you've just been listening to absolute mayhem and chaos for the first few minutes. But, welcome to episode 161 this is our third i don't even know if it's our i think it's our third holiday special could be our fourth who knows and as promised the returning guest from episodes 117 to 121 inclusive probably the funniest the most entertaining guest we've had of all time zach lane is with us for the holiday special and uh how you doing zach i mean we'll link your previous episodes it's good to
我无法保持我们……这太诡异了。好了。我的意思是，这可能最终都会播进节目里，所以你们在前几分钟里听到的绝对是一片混乱和疯狂。但是，欢迎来到第 161 期节目，这是我们的第三个，我甚至不知道是不是我们的，我想是我们的第三个节日特别节目，也可能是第四个，谁知道呢。正如承诺的那样，从第 117 期到第 121 期（包含中间期数）的回归嘉宾，可能也是我们有史以来最有趣、最具娱乐性的嘉宾，扎克·莱恩和我们一起参加节日特别节目，呃，你最近怎么样，扎克？我们会附上你之前的节目链接，很高兴
have you back how have you been it's gonna be back yeah i've been i've been good it's um it's it's uh i think that the show is much more um since being on the show, like I had heard several episodes of the show before. But now it's become like a regular thing. Like I listen to it all the time. So I've been keeping up with you guys a lot better than I usually do. If you want to expand your listenership, you just got to get people to come on one at a time. Just a few million people away from really great numbers. That's a strategy oh man so kind of what are you traveling for right now oh uh i was in i am in san diego for at least for a couple more hours for the weekend
你能回来，你最近怎么样？很高兴回来，是的，我一直，我一直很好，呃，我认为这个节目变得更加，自从上了这个节目之后，就像我之前听过这个节目的好几期。但现在它变成了一件常规的事情。就像我一直在听一样。所以我比平时更好地跟上了你们的进度。如果你想扩大听众群，你只需要让人家一次来一个人。距离真正的好成绩只差几百万听众了。这真是一个策略，天哪，太客气了。你现在是因为什么在旅行呢？哦，呃，我在圣迭戈，至少还要待几个小时，为了周末的一个半程马拉松。你的成绩是多少？是一小时 11 分 16 秒。哇。我完全不知道这算好还是坏。这，这，这相当快。
for a half marathon. What was your time? It was one hour, 11 minutes and 16 seconds. Wow. I have no idea whether that's good or bad. That's, that's, that's pretty fast.
哦。我完全不知道这算好还是坏。这，这，这相当快。
Yeah. Yeah. So, so since I've been listening to the, to the show more, there are a couple of things that stand out like one is that it's never not funny to me when bryce gets 10x i mean i laugh every single time you would think it would get old but it never gets old i'm laughing i'm giggling in my desk people like what is he listening to
是的。所以，自从我更多地收听这个节目以来，有几件事很突出，一是我每次听到布莱斯说 10x 的时候都会觉得非常搞笑，我是说我每次都笑。你可能会觉得这会过时，但它永远不会过时。我在笑，我在办公桌前咯咯笑，人们问：“他在听什么？”
i'm like i'm listening to bryce be low-key trolled by his co-host and it's amazing and uh another thing is um there was one episode we were talking about what the universal algorithm is uh you know and and you guys were trying to figure out a name for it and i was just yelling the unigrhythm at my terminal which is the the best slash worst name for the universal algorithm um and and the the the last bit of outstanding business is you were also talking about what alternative names you could come up with for ADSP, like what initialism it could map back onto. And my favorite one is, oh, damn, shit's popping with Bryce and Connor. But the funny thing is, like, as soon as you said that, I could not stop thinking of like four-letter initialisms. Like I came up with like 50 of them that day.
我说：“我听的是布莱斯被他的搭档低调地钓鱼，这太棒了。”呃，还有一件事，呃，有一期节目我们讨论什么是通用算法，你知道的，你们俩试图想一个名字，我当时就对着我的终端大喊“Unigrhythm”，这是给通用算法起的最棒也是最糟的名字。最后一个悬而未决的事项是，你们当时还在讨论可以为 ADSP 起什么替代名字，比如它可以对应成什么首字母缩写。我最喜欢的一个是：哦，damn，shit's popping with Bryce and Connor（哦，该死，布莱斯和康纳的节目太火爆了）。但有趣的是，就像你一说出来，我就忍不住去想四个字母的首字母缩写。比如那天我想出了大约 50 个。
I don't remember any of them except that one. But I mean I was like – I literally – I couldn't sleep that night. I was like, oh, that one works too. I was like – I don't know if you guys have trouble falling asleep. But this is what my brain does when it's time to lay down. I'm like thinking of stupid shit that doesn't matter and I can't stop thinking about it. So yeah, that took over my brain for about 24 hours that's pretty fun this is fantastic odd damn shit's popping uh that's clearly gonna be the cold open uh
除了那一个之外，我一个也不记得了。但我的意思是，我当时——我真的——那天晚上我睡不着觉。我在想，哦，那个也行。我当时——我不知道你们是不是也经常失眠。但这就是我的大脑在准备睡觉时的运作方式。我会去想那些无关紧要的蠢事，而且还停不下来。所以，是的，这占据了我的大脑大约 24 小时。这挺有趣的。这太棒了。哦，damn，shit's popping，呃，这显然会成为开场白，呃……
apparently we need to actually really read the book adsb because we've uh we've talked about pascal a bit now yeah do we both own it i don't think i actually own it i have a dragon book and i have eop i don't think i have it because i was looking for it when we were recording the episode the other day well that's blasphemy you should own it yeah i've heard it talked about a bunch i've never read it either i've read eop like you know multiple times uh because because you have to to it, you have to read it multiple times. But ADSP, I've never actually read. EOP is like, and so that's Elements of Programming by Ag Stepanov.
显然我们需要真正去读一读这本书《ADSP》，因为我们现在已经呃讨论了一点帕斯卡了。是的，我们俩都有这本书吗？我觉得我其实没有。我有《龙书》，我还有《EOP》，我觉得我没有这本书，因为我前几天录节目的时候找过它。那简直是亵渎，你应该拥有一本。是的，我经常听到别人谈论它，但我从来没读过。我读过好几次《EOP》，你知道的，因为你必须去读它，你必须读好几遍。但《ADSP》，我其实从来没读过。《EOP》就像是——所以那是阿格·斯捷帕诺夫写的《编程元素》。
And Paul McJones too. Yeah, and Paul McJones. Sorry, sorry, Paul McJones. Well, I mean, to hear the telling of how the book came to be, like, and you should have Sean talk about it. It's really kind of fascinating. But, you know, Sean kind of made room for those guys who were Adobe employees at the time to, like, write this book kind of on company time. And the way he tells it, like, Stepanov had all these great ideas and Paul McJones was the one that kept pushing him to finish. So, like, they co-wrote the book together. But the point is that, like, without Paul McJones, the one that kept pushing him to finish. So like they co-wrote the book together.
还有保罗·麦琼斯。是的，还有保罗·麦琼斯。抱歉，抱歉，保罗·麦琼斯。好吧，我是说，听听这本书是怎么诞生的故事，你可以找肖恩聊聊。真的挺吸引人的。但是，你知道，肖恩当时腾出空间给那些当时是 Adobe 员工的家伙们，让他们可以在公司上班时间写这本书。照他所说，斯捷帕诺夫有很多伟大的想法，而保罗·麦琼斯则是那个不断催促他完成的人。所以，他们是一起合著这本书的。但重点是，没有保罗·麦琼斯，那个不断催促他完成的人。所以他们合著了这本书。
But the point is that like without Paul McJones, there is no EOP, right? It wasn't just like – and also Paul McJones is here. He was like the guy who was the motivating force to get it finished when Stepanoff had these great ideas but that he didn't have a lot of follow-through. That's from – again, Sean's telling of it. It is a very good book. And like I really don't read Berman books, but I have read a good chunk of this one. Yeah, and it's so dense that like I think I mentioned this actually last time I was on, but it bears repeating that like I took the first, I want to say six or seven pages of the first chapter.
但重点是，没有保罗·麦琼斯，就没有《EOP》，对吧？这不仅仅是——而且保罗·麦琼斯也在场。他就像是那个推动者，在斯捷帕诺夫有伟大想法但缺乏执行力时，促成了这本书的完成。这是——再次引用肖恩的说法。这是一本非常好的书。而且我真的不怎么读这类书，但我读了这本书很大一部分。是的，它非常紧凑，我想我上次上节目时其实提到过这一点，但值得重申的是，我拿了第一章的前面，我想是六七页的内容，
And I turned that into a one-hour talk about how to design types and why you make the design decisions you make. And it is incredibly useful because one of the things that I found when I first started working at C++, you know, you get this multi-paradigm language. It's got the legacy of C stuff. It's got the newer style stuff. It's got all these idioms from the newer stuff and all these different paradigms that usually come from the newer parts. And it's really overwhelming for a new programmer, right? You know, it's like, oh, well, I've seen people use getters and setters and I see people put public data members. I don't know which one to use or why. And that's just one tiny question, right? There's dozens of questions like that. And if you have some kind of rubric
然后我把它变成了一个一小时的演讲，内容是关于如何设计类型以及为什么你要做出那样的设计决策。这真的极其有用。因为我刚开始在 C++ 工作时发现的一件事是，你接触到的是一个多范式语言。它有 C 语言的遗留内容，有较新风格的内容，有来自较新内容的所有这些习惯用法，以及通常来自较新部分的各种不同范式。对于一个新程序员来说，这真的让人不知所措，对吧？你知道的，就像，哦，好吧，我看到人们使用 getter 和 setter，我也看到人们使用公共数据成员。我不知道该用哪个，或者为什么要用。这只是一个小问题，对吧？像这样的小问题有几十个。如果你有一些关于如何进行设计的准则，
around which to make designs, and I think those first few pages of the first EOP chapter do that, it makes everything clear. It makes it clear, like, why do these things work this way? Why should I make decisions? What's the basis for doing so? So that book is really amazing. The later parts of it, it's interesting because later parts of it are like all about like algorithm design and you kind of see like where parts of the STL came from and stuff. But ultimately, if you already know the STL and use it, I think the later parts of the book, while they're interesting or not as revelatory as like the very first chapter, which is so dense. Yeah, it's so dense. And if you internalize that first chapter, it's huge. A large chunk of the rest of the book is about iterator abstractions and different methods
我认为《EOP》第一章的那前几页就是这样做的，它让一切都变得清晰明了。它解释得很清楚，比如：为什么这些事情要这样运作？我为什么要做出决策？这样做的基础是什么？所以这本书真的很神奇。后半部分很有意思，因为后半部分都是关于算法设计的，你可以看到 STL 的某些部分是从哪里来的，诸如此类。但归根结底，如果你已经了解并使用了 STL，我认为这本书的后半部分虽然很有趣，但并不像第一章那样具有颠覆性，第一章的内容实在是太紧凑了。是的，太紧凑了。如果你内化了第一章的内容，那收获将是巨大的。本书其余的大部分内容都是关于迭代器抽象以及不同的迭代方法和算法设计哲学的。但第一章叫做“基础”。我这里正好有版权页，我来读一下。每一章开头都有一个简短的总结，我用了一种不同的字体，因为它们是核心主题，代表了计算机中不同类别的思想。书中一个核心的概念——“规律性”（regularity）被引入并进行了详细阐述。当应用于过程时，规律性意味着过程对相等的参数返回相等的结果。当应用于类型时，规律性意味着类型拥有相等运算符以及保持相等的拷贝构造和赋值。规律性使我们能够应用等式推理，用相等者替换相等者来转换和优化程序。所以这一章也讨论了 C 语言中值类型的很多哲学，即过程的规律性，并且在斯捷帕诺夫的世界观中，规律性不仅仅是
and philosophies for iteration and algorithm design. But the first chapter is called Foundations. And I actually have my copyright here. I'll read. There's a little summary at the start of each chapter and I a different font because they're like key themes, that represent different categories of ideas in the computer. A central notion of the book, regularity, is introduced and elaborated. When applied to procedures, regularity means that procedures return equal results for equal arguments. When applied to types, regularity means that types possess the equality operator and equality preserving copy construction and assignment. Regularity enables us to apply equational reasoning, substituting equals for equals to transform and optimize programs. So there's a lot of the philosophy of value types in C that this chapter also talks about the regularity of procedures and that in, in Stepanov's worldview, um, regularity was something that was not just
关于你的数据类型的。这也是他有意引入的一个总体概念，并将其同时应用于类型和过程。是的，绝对是这样的，而且，你从函数式编程语言中对函数的直觉（即什么是函数），或多或少就是正则函数（regular function）的概念，对吧？我不确定是否存在任何具体的差异。我认为它们基本上是一回事。但出于某些技术原因，即使不完全是一回事，也非常相似。就像你可以从高层次的抽象上去思考它，把它看作是一个纯函数式编程语言中的函数。这很好，因为你可以用纯函数很好地进行推理，对吧？
about your, your data types. It was also something that, that, that he intentionally, um, introduced this one overarching concept and then applied it to both types and, uh, procedures. Yeah, absolutely. And, And that, you know, your intuition from a functional programming language of what a function is, is the notion of regular function more or less, right? I'm not sure if there's any concrete differences. I think there's basically the same thing. But it's very similar if it's not exactly the same thing for some technical reasons. Like you can think of it at the high level of abstraction as being like a function from a pure functional programming language. And it's nice because like you can reason about things so well with pure functions, right?
这就是为什么函数式编程语言在一定程度上很受欢迎。这也是为什么人们喜欢它们。你从中获得的价值在于你可以对它们进行的轻松推理，对吧？而且，每当我看到带有输出引用或指针参数的函数时，我就会想，那东西为什么在那儿？有时候你确实需要它。比如，构造函数，对吧？构造函数无法返回任何东西。所以如果出于某种原因需要从构造函数中获取某些东西，你就必须放置一个输出参数，对吧？这种情况虽然不常见，但确实会出现。但像正则函数一样，你可以返回一个元组，老兄。
And so that's why functional programming languages are popular to the extent they are. That's why people like them. That's the value that you get from them is that the ease of reasoning that you can apply to them, right? And, you know, whenever I see a function with an out ref or pointer param, I'm like, why is that there? Like, sometimes you really need it. Like, let's say a constructor, right? There's no way to return anything from a constructor. So you have to put an out param to get something out of a constructor if there's some reason to do that, right? It doesn't come up very often, but it does come up. But like regular functions, like, you know, return a tuple, dude.
把那个值作为输入，然后作为输出返回。现在有一些例外情况，比如传递非常大的对象，你知道的，在非内联函数中，如果不进行大量拷贝，那真的行不通。所以有些情况下你应该这样做，也有一些情况下你不应该遵循我刚才说的、只传值和返回值的原则。但非常常见的情况是，人们传递一些诸如布尔值“成功与否”之类的输出参数。我就想：返回一个 optional 吧。
Like take that value as an input and return as an output. Now there's some things, there are partial exceptions to that, like passing very large objects, you know, in a non-inline function that doesn't really work without making a big copy. So there are some things you should do that, there's some cases where you shouldn't follow what I just said and just pass in a value and pass out the value. But very frequently people pass out parameters that are like a Boolean succeeded or not or something like this. I'm like return an optional.
这样对代码进行推理要容易得多。而且在词法上阅读和编写也更加简单。如果你身边带着这个多余的 bool 值，必须传进去，然后它就一直挂在那里，你知道的，这本身就会带来各种问题。是的，完全同意。你知道，关于这本书的一个迷人之处，你在第一章就能看到，那就是：是的，从那段描述听起来，这似乎是一本非常抽象、非常理论化的书。但事实并非如此。斯捷帕诺夫非常擅长建立理论，同时也非常贴近计算机的实际运作方式。比如，在本章中他定义了什么是“值”的那一部分，他谈到了……你知道的，比如二进制中的表示形式，
It's so much easier to reason about your code that way. And it's just easier lexically just to read and write it. Like if you have this extra bool sitting around that you have to pass in and then it's just hanging around, you know, that's just problematic for its own kind of reasons. Yeah, totally agree. You know, one of the fascinating things about this book in general, and you see it just in like the first chapter, is like, yeah, like from that description, it sounds like this is like going to be like a very abstract, very theoretical book. But that's not what it is. Stepanov is very good at building up theory but also remaining pretty close to how computers actually work like in in in in the section of this um chapter where he uh defines what like a value is um he he's talking about you know like uh representations
并且他举了例子，比如谈到表示浮点数和 IEEE 754 的具体例子，非常底层的东西。所以它绝对不是一本不切实际的书，他将计算机如何工作以及如何在这些计算机上获得性能，与优秀的计算机科学理论结合起来的能力，才是真正让这本书如此强大的原因。是的。所以，如果你已经被说服了，那就去亚马逊，使用优惠码
in binary um and like he's he gives examples you know like like uh talking about specific examples of representing you know floating point numbers and iEEE 754, like very low-level stuff. And so it's in no way, I very, um, practical, uh, book and in his ability to, um, uh, to tie together both, um, how computers work and how you get performance on those computers with,
“Shit's popping”今天就去买一本。它实际上已经绝版了，这有点令人悲伤，但好消息是，因为已经绝版，而且斯捷帕诺夫和麦琼斯对此开了绿灯，出版商也同意了，你可以拿到免费的 PDF。所以任何听到这个节目且还没看过的朋友，你们都应该去看看。你们应该去下载那个 PDF。我认为迭代器的抽象最棒的一点在于，就像你说的，他从计算机在做什么开始，然后让我们做出概括这一过程的抽象。所以在其他语言中有一个“光标”（cursor）的概念。我想也许 Rust 做过类似的事情，就是你拥有对被索引对象的引用，再加上一些值来指示在对象中的什么地方进行索引，对吧？
you know, uh, uh, good computer science theory is really what makes it such a strong book. Yeah. So if you've been persuaded by this, head over to Amazon, use promo code.
所以这就是你的表示方式。因此它是一个索引。所以，你知道，这其中的一个好处是，只要你所指向的东西的大小超过了索引的位置，它就不会失效。你可以进行一些非常简单的检查来确保这一点仍然成立，这与指针不同，使用指针时你可能会指向太空深处，而你根本无法检测到。所以不那样做有一些优势。但斯捷帕诺夫的观点是：指针是基础。计算机就是这样工作的。你的芯片组中的指令集架构（ISA）就是这样工作的。不管是什么 ISA，它都在使用指针。它使用诸如此类的地址来引用内存位置。
Shit's popping to get your copy today. It's actually out of print, which is kind of sad, but the good news is because it's out of print and stepping off of McJones, like signed off on this and they got the publisher signed off on it. You can get us a free PDF. So anybody who can hear this and hasn't checked it out, you should do it. You should grab the PDF. One of the things I think is so great about the abstraction of an iterator is that, like you said, he started with what is the computer doing, and let's make abstractions that generalize that. So there's a notion of a cursor in other languages. I think maybe Rust does something like this where it's like, you know, you've got a reference to the object being indexed into and then some value that says where to index into the object, right?
所以这些考虑都包含在其中。而且，我知道有很多人，这不仅仅吸引 C++ 爱好者，还有更广泛的受众。这本书以 C++ 作为例子。但实际上它是一本关于计算机科学的书。让我感兴趣的是，在 C++ 圈子之外，甚至在 C++ 社区的一个子集里，它并不是一本广为人知的书。但实际上，你可以把所有这些经验教训应用到任何语言中，对吧？比如，有一些编写代码的基本方法，能让代码更容易推理，第一次写就能写对，并且更难犯错，诸如此类。这真的是非常非常棒的内容。是的。所以，关于迭代器抽象这个话题，当他在书中引入迭代器时，他写道：
So that's your representation. So it's an index. So, you know, one of the nice things about that is it doesn't get invalidated as long as the size of the thing you're pointing to exceeds the position of the index. And you can do some very easy checks to make sure that's still true, unlike a pointer, where you can have like, it's such a pointer pointing off into space, you have no way of detecting that. So some advantages of not doing it that way. But stepping off was coming from the point of view that like, pointers are fundamental. This is how the computer works. This is how your ISA works in your chipset. Doesn't matter what ISA it is, it's using pointers. It's using like the addresses of things to refer to locations of memory.
“迭代器是一个概念族，它们抽象了地址的不同方面。”紧接着这一段，他基本上解释了什么是内存地址，以及每个对象都有一个内存地址这个概念。所以我觉得这非常有趣，他呈现迭代器的方式完全如你所说：
So those kind of considerations are in there. And, you know, I know there's a lot of people that, you know, this has a more broad appeal than just C++ people. And that book uses C++ as an example. But really it's a book about computer science. And that's the thing that's interesting to me is that outside of C++ circles and even, you know, a subset of C++ kind of community, it's not a well-known book. But really, you can take all those lessons and apply it to any language, right? Like there are fundamental ways of writing code that's easier to reason about, easier
这是一个抽象。这是地址、指针的一种更通用的形式。是的。我认为这并不是我们对迭代器的许多心理模型。通常我们认为，哦，这是一种抽象了迭代的东西。但实际上，它是从头开始设计的，
to get right the first time you write it, and harder to make mistakes and stuff like that. It's just really, really good stuff. Yeah. So, so, so on that, uh, uh, topic of, you know, uh, the iterator abstraction, the, when, when he introduces iterators in this book, um, he, he writes, uh, iterators are a family of concepts that abstract different aspects of addresses. And this is right after a paragraph where he basically explains what a memory address is and this idea that every object has a memory address. And so I think that's very interesting that the way that he presents iterators are exactly like what you said.
旨在作为指针这一概念的硬件抽象。你知道，最近我一直在处理 JavaScript，因为我在工作中使用了一个基于网页的数据可视化工具。让我有点困惑的一点是，我知道那些处理解释型语言的人，特别是——但你知道，大多数不是“分号语言”（正如某人曾经称呼它们的那样，我想这个词可能是这个播客里冒出来的，或者有人这么叫过它们）的语言。但是，有一大类语言，你根本不需要知道什么是指针，对吧？然后当人们转向 C 和 C++ 时，他们就会想：“哇，这个指针是个什么东西？”但让我疯狂的是，你已经在处理一个“万物皆指针”的语言了，对吧？
This is an abstraction. This is a more general form of an address, of a pointer. Yeah. And I think that that's not what a lot of our mental models typically are of iterators. Usually we think of it as, oh, well, this is something that abstracts iteration. But really, it was designed from the ground up
你只需要把所有的规则都内化。而且解引用或获取某个东西的引用的语法是固定的。没有其他选项来决定怎么做。而且某个东西什么时候表现得像指针、什么时候不是，这些都是固定的。你只需要知道区别。你已经把所有这些规则都内化了。所以，你知道，在 JavaScript 中，你无法编写一个交换（swap）函数，对吧？你不能说：给定这个函数的 A 值和 B 值，让我交换它们的值。
to be an abstraction of the hardware of this notion of a pointer. You know, one of the things, so I've been dealing with JavaScript a lot lately because I've been working this data visualization tool that's a web-based thing at work. And one of the things that kind of gets me is I know that people that deal with interpreted languages in particular, but, you know, most languages that aren't, as someone once called them, a semicolon language. I think it maybe even came from this podcast or someone called them that. But, like, there's a whole class of languages for which you just don't have to know what a pointer is, right? And then when people go to C and C++, they're like, whoa, what is this pointer thing? But what drives me crazy about that is you already deal with a language that everything is a pointer, right?
你就是写不出来，我的意思是，也许你可以做一些像把 JSON 字符串化然后解析，然后你得到一个新对象，你从 B 那里拿过来赋值给 A，然后再把 A 赋值给某个临时变量。所以你可以搞一些奇奇怪怪的东西，但你不能只是把这两个值（它们是指向两个真实事物的指针）拿来，然后说：不管它们指向哪里，让它们指向彼此相反的东西。你就是写不出这样的代码。
And you just had to internalize all the rules. And then the syntax of dereferencing or taking a reference to something is fixed. There's not options of how to do it. And it's also the times in which something acts like a pointer and doesn't are fixed. And you just have to know the difference. And you've already internalized all these rules. So like, you know, in JavaScript, you can't write like a swap function, right? You can't say like, given values A and B to this function, let me swap their values.
所以如果你写 A 等于 B 这样的代码，你实际上是用指针 B 覆盖了指针 A。所以现在 A 和 B 指向了同一个东西，并且它们共享了状态。所以它本质上是一个非正则语言。它真的很难推理。如果你对传递的某些参数进行修改，它看起来就像一个值参数。有时你把它当作值使用。有时你对它进行赋值。当你对它进行赋值时，你是在覆盖变量的本地副本。但如果你通过它使用点操作符对对象进行变异操作，你实际上是在
Like you just can't write it because, I mean, I think maybe you can do like something where you like stringify the JSON and then parse it and then you get a new object and you take that from B and assign that to A, and then you assigned A to some temporary. So you could do some funky stuff, but you can't just take these two values, which are pointers to two real things, right? And you can't say whatever they point to, make them point to the opposite of each other. That's just not something you can write.
变异你传递给函数的那个对象，并且在函数外部是可见的。所以某个东西是否是局部更改是很微妙的。我的意思是，这真的很难对这些代码进行推理。然后人们却说：“但是指针太难理解了。”而我就想：“真的是这样吗？”比如，我只是不觉得——你知道，只用值，你就很棒了。你知道，我无法用言语表达——我绝不是一个经验丰富的 Python 程序员。我认为我写 Python 代码挺烂的。而且最明显的问题在于，我不知道，我不知道“Pythonic”（地道的 Python 风格）是什么样的。我不知道编写 Python 代码的习惯用法是什么。所以最后我写出来的 Python 代码看起来非常像我的 C++ 代码。
And so if you do something like A equals B, you're assigning the pointer B over the pointer of A. So now A and B now point to the same thing and they've shared state. So it's an inherently non-regular language. It's really hard to reason about. If you make mutations to some parameters that you're passing, like it just looks like a value parameter. Sometimes you use it as a value. Sometimes you assign to it. And when you assign to it, you're assigning over the local copy of the variable. But if you assign through it using a dot, like mutating operation on the object, you're actually
但我记不清有多少次，当我正在编写某个 Python 函数时，我会想：“我糊涂了。我这里操作的是本地副本吗？如果我修改了这个东西，我会修改调用函数里的那个东西吗？”我根本没有对应的心理模型。我的意思是，我认为任何这样的语言——除了像 Hilo 那样纯粹基于值的系统，或者像许多函数式语言那样纯粹基于值的系统——如果不是这种语言，那么你就会某种对象模型，它具有某种形式的引用和共享状态，以及对指针的某种形式的抽象。而且，好吧，C++ 的确有很多容易踩坑的地方（foot guns），但我并不认为它一定比 Python 或 JavaScript 等语言的对象模型更难理解。它只是不同。它相当不同。我想是这样的。特别是，最让我对 Hilo 感到兴奋的是——
mutating the object you pass to the function, and it's visible from outside the function. So whether something is a local change or not is subtle. And I mean, it's like really hard to reason about this code. And then people are like, but pointers are so hard to think about. And I'm like, are they though? Like, I just don't, you know, just use values and you're great. You know, I, I, I cannot tell you the number and I, I am by no means, um, uh, an expert Python programmer. I think I'm, uh, pretty bad at writing Python code. And I think most notably the problem is that I don't, I don't know, like the Pythonic way. I don't know, like, what's the idiomatic way to write Python code. So I end up writing Python code that looks a lot like my C++ code.
作为一个项目，以及它未来某天可能会作为安全模式引入 C++ 的面向值模型的语义。它比做 Rust 版本更让我兴奋的原因是，你知道，Rust 解决了在 C++ 和 C 中编写代码的问题：到处都是引用语义，到处都是共享状态，当你拥有引用语义时，对吧？所以他们说：“好吧，让我们更难写出我们用引用语义犯下的那些错误。”
But I can't count the number of times when I've been writing some Python function and I've been like, I'm confused. Am I working with a local copy here? If I modify this thing, am I going to modify the thing in the calling function? And I just don't have the mental model for it. And I mean, I think that any language like that, other than a language, something like maybe like Hilo, where it's like purely a value-based system or like, you know, a lot of functional languages where it's purely value-based. If it's not a language like that, then you've got some sort of object model that has some form of references and shared state and some form of abstraction over pointers. And, you know, okay, the C++ one has a lot of foot guns, but I don't think that it's necessarily harder to understand than the object model of like a language like Python or JavaScript. It's just different. It's just quite different. I think that's right. And in particular, the thing that excites me about Hilo
所以他们有一个非常复杂的检查器，不允许你编写你知道是安全的东西，即使它们确实安全，只是因为它没有适当的启发式方法来涵盖这种情况。有一些类似这样的小毛病，而且编译需要很长时间。这是一个每个人都必须适应的中间模型，诸如此类。这本身并没有什么本质上的错误，但就像我写 C++ 代码时，一切都是值，我不需要这样做，对吧？我不必担心引用以及某个东西是否悬空，因为每当我使用指针时，它们就像是内部的实现细节，对吧？而在最顶层，一切都是值。所以当你编写这样的代码时，你不必担心这些事情。而 Hilo 似乎正在拥抱这一点。就像：“哦，好吧，与其试图把所有那些奇怪的东西搞对，不如干脆不做那些奇怪的东西，也不让你做那些奇怪的东西。”
as a project and as something that might be the semantics of what its value oriented model looks like might be bolted onto C++ as a safe mode at some point in the future. The reason that is more exciting to me than doing a Rust version of it is you know rust took the problem with writing code in c plus plus and c is it there's reference semantics everywhere the shared state everywhere when you have reference semantics right and so they said well let's make it harder to write those mistakes that we write we use reference semantics.
所以我上大学时有个室友。刚毕业后，他去日本教了一段时间英语。他说他在那里的时候，那大约是 90 年代末，比如 97 年左右。当时他们出了几款车型，仪表盘上带电视。所以作为司机，你可以在开车时看电视。每个买这车的人都觉得这主意听起来太棒了，对吧？所以所有拥有这些车的人，不出所料，一直在出车祸，对吧？所以政府没有说：“嘿，你们不能在汽车仪表盘上装电视，”
And so they have this very elaborate checker that doesn't let you write things that you know are safe, even though they're not because it doesn't have the proper heuristics to cover that case. There's a few warts like this, and it takes a long time to compile. It's a middle model that everybody has to get ramped up on and stuff. And there's nothing inherently wrong with it, but it's just like when I write, when I write C++ code, everything's a value and I don't have to do this, right? I don't have to worry about references and whether something's dangling or not because whenever I have pointers, they're like implementation details inside of stuff, right? And everything's a value at the top level. And so when you write code like that, you don't have to worry about these things. And Hilo seems to be embracing that. Like, oh, well, let's instead of like trying to get all the weird stuff right, let's just not do the weird stuff and not let you do the weird stuff.
而是说：“如果你买了一辆带仪表盘电视的车，你就必须参加这个政府赞助的课程，学习如何在看电视的同时安全驾驶。”对吧？对我来说，这就是 Rust。这就是 Rust 决定要做的事情。他们就像是：“你知道你选择做的这件疯狂的事情吗，比如把引用用于一切？让我们把它变安全吧。”而我就想：“为什么？为什么要那样做？”
So I had this housemate in college. And right after school, he went to teach English in Japan for a while. And he said while he was there, this was in like the late 90s, like 97 or something. And they had a few models of cars that were coming out at the time that had TVs in the dashboard. So as the driver, you could watch TV while you were driving. And everyone who bought one, yeah, sounds great idea, right? So all these people with these cars, they were getting in accidents all the time, as you would expect, right? So instead of the government saying, hey, you can't put TVs in the dashboard of cars,
我的意思是，我理解。比如，结果确实很好。对吧。但我觉得有更好的方法来切入同一个问题。是的。我的意思是，这不禁让人纳闷，为什么以前没有人尝试过类似的事情？我想，我认为，你在 High-low 和 Rust 身上遇到的挑战是，你会失去一定程度的控制，而对于系统编程来说，这种控制的丧失往往会导致性能的下降、导致无法以最快的方式编写代码。是的，这就是为什么我们——这就是为什么系统编程一直倾向于那些让你拥有高度控制权和高度掌控力的语言。
they instead said, if you buy a dashboard TV car, you have to take this government-sponsored class that teaches you how to drive your car safely while watching TV. Right? And to me, that's rust. Like that's what rust has decided to do. They're like, you know this insane thing you chose to do, like use references for everything? Let's make that safe. And I'm like, why? Why do that?
所以，好吧，说到我超级兴奋的未来特性，呃，我想你可能参加了那个会议，布莱斯，但在上一次 C++ 会议上，我们有一个关于元编程和反射的会议。是的，你参加了那个会议，对吧？他们展示了——所以有一些致力于编译器的开发人员，他们把这当作一项任务：我们要实现某些功能，并撰写支持实现的论文。他们的进展比房间里除了他们之外的任何人预期的要远得多。现在看起来，虽然不能保证，但我们有可能会在 C++26 中得到这个特性。我认为我们在 26 中引入反射的可能性相当大。我认为可能性也很大。
I mean, I understand. Like has good results. Right. But, but I think there's a, there's a better way of slicing the same problem. Yeah. I mean, it makes, makes, makes one wonder why hasn't something like, uh, been, been attempted before. I think, I think, um, I think that the challenge that you have with both something like high-low and and rust is that you you lose some degree of control um uh and and for systems programming that that that can that loss of control can often lead to a loss of uh performance loss of ability to write something in the the fastest way yeah and that's that's why we've we've oh we that's why systems programming has gravitated towards languages where you have a great degree of control and a great degree of what comes yeah yeah so okay speaking of like future stuff that i'm super excited about uh the uh i think you were maybe in this session
但我不想在所有听众面前使用那个以 L 开头的词（Likely，可能的），因为我不想树立可能不会实现的期望。但我确实认为很有可能。是的，我不会轻易使用这个词，但我看好它的胜算。是的，我也这么看，尤其是因为每个人都对此感到兴奋。甚至房间里那些持有竞争方法的家伙们也说：“不，不，这很好。你们已经做到了。”
uh bryce but at the last c++ meeting we had a session on uh metaprogramming and reflection yeah and uh you were in that session right and they showed like so there are some people that you know work on compilers that have taken this on as like we're going to implement something and and and write papers supporting the implementation and they were so much farther along than i think anyone in that room besides them suspected. And now it looks like there is no guarantee, but there is a chance that we're going to get that for 26. I think it's pretty likely that we'll get reflection in 26. I think it's likely, too.
你们有一个实现。它正在运作。人们已经在使用参考实现、编译器的演示模式来构建很酷的库了。人们的想法就是：“是的，让我们把它加进去吧。让我们把它搞定。”一旦人们从“但你没有按我的方式做”转变为“让我们把它放进去吧”，事情往往就会推进得相当快。是的。所以对此我真的非常兴奋。你知道你需要请谁来这个播客吗？是迈克尔·帕克（Michael Park），来谈谈反射，因为他有一个目前还没有人实现的反射提案，我认为这正是目前的巨大阻碍。等等，是他有反射提案还是模式匹配？
But I didn't want to use the L word in front of all of our listeners because I don't want to build expectations of something that might not happen. But I do think it's likely. Yeah. I don't use it lightly, but I like its odds. Yeah, I do too, especially because everyone is excited about it. And even people that were in the room that had competing approaches were like, no, no, that's fine. You guys have done it.
哦，我总是说错——我已经跟好几个人这么说过了。他们说：“我觉得你糊涂了。”我说：“是的，我很糊涂。”不，不，我本来想说的是模式匹配。但是，是的，他有一个非常非常有趣的模式匹配提案，真的考虑得非常周到。他对大约 13 种已经存在模式匹配的其他语言进行了大规模的调研，他可以试用这些语言并观察其语义，因此他做出了 C++ 版本的模式匹配，真的很棒。
You have an implementation. It's working. People are building cool libraries with it already with the reference implementation, with the demo mode of your program, your compiler. And people are just like, yeah, let's just get it in. Let's just get it done. And that kind of thing, once people shift away from like,
最酷的是，他已经思考这件事很长时间了。比如，我想我第一次和他谈论这个是在 2017 年或 2018 年左右。我的意思是，他着手研究这个已经有一段时间了，对吧？所以每当有人提出问题时，他就会拿出那篇论文，向你展示语义。甚至还有语言语法的一部分之类的东西。他也在语法层面进行思考，所以他不会漏掉任何东西。他会提出一些观点，然后你会说：“哦，但是这个呢？”他会说：“哦，是的。”然后他会谈论它，就好像这是一个他从未听过的新想法一样。最后他说：“是的，这就是为什么我不那样做，因为……”
but you didn't do it my way to like, let's just get it in there, things tend to move pretty quickly. Yeah. Yeah. So I'm really excited about that. And then you know who you need to get on this podcast is Michael Park to talk about reflection because he has a reflection proposal that no one has implemented yet, which is the big, I think, blocker for it right now. Wait, he does or pattern matching?
“我觉得由于我们刚才得出的那些原因，它行不通。”你试图难倒他，或者试图想出一个“那……呢？”的问题，但从来没用，因为他已经把一切都考虑到了。当人们对一个话题达到这种流利程度时，真的让人非常兴奋。无论如何，我认为 26 年前实现这一点的可能性为零，但我真的很希望我们能在 29 年的时间框架内实现它。我觉得那会太棒了。如果我们能同时拥有这两样东西，我的意思是，那将是编写 C++ 方式的又一次颠覆性改变。我认为仅凭反射本身就会非常
Oh, I keep saying the wrong – I've said that to multiple people. They're like, I think you're confused. I'm like, yes, I am confused. No, no, pattern matching is what I was trying to say. But, yeah, he's got a really, really interesting proposal for pattern matching that is like really well thought out he's done a huge survey of I think like 13 different languages that have pattern matching in it you know that already in some other language in existence and he could try it out and see if the semantics and so he's done the C++ version of that and it's really great and
具有影响力。如果我们在 26 中引入反射，它将成为一个重大版本。我一直在做题为《C++ 的地平线》的演讲，在演讲中我谈到了我最兴奋的三件事以及 C++ 的未来。它们是：反射、模式匹配和发送者（senders）。我很高兴看到我们在反射方面取得了进展，因为之前它似乎停滞了一段时间。
the cool thing about it is like he's been thinking about this for a very long time. Like, I think the first conversation I ever had with him about this was in, like, 2017 or 2018. I mean, like, it goes back a while that he's been working on this, right? And so whenever someone has a question, like, you know, he'll bring up, like, the paper, and he'll show you, like, the semantics. And he even has, like, you know, part'll bring up like the paper and he'll show you like the semantics and even has like, you know, part of the grammar for language and stuff. He's thinking about the grammar level too, so he doesn't miss anything. And he'll bring something up and you'll say like, oh, but what about this? He's like, oh yeah. And then he'll talk about it like it's a new idea that he's never heard before. And at the end he's like, yeah, so that's why I'm not doing it that way because like,
最酷的事情是，他已经思考这件事很长时间了。比如，我想我第一次和他谈起这个是在2017年或2018年左右。我的意思是，他着手研究这个已经有一段时间了，对吧？所以每当有人提出问题时，你知道的，他就会拿出那篇论文，向你展示语义。他甚至连语言的部分语法之类的东西都考虑到了。他连语法层面都在思考，所以他不会漏掉任何东西。他会提出一些观点，然后你会说，哦，那这个呢？他会说，哦，对啊。然后他会谈论它，就好像这是一个他从未听过的新想法一样。最后他说，对，所以这就是为什么我不那样做的原因，因为
I don't think it works for the reasons we just came to like you try to stump him or you try to come up with a what about and then it never works because he's thought of everything um and when people have that level of fluency with the topic it's just really exciting so anyway i don't think there's any chance that'll happen by 26 but i'm really hoping that we can get that in the 29 time frame i think that'd be awesome and if we had both of those things i mean that would be another seismic change in how 29 time frame. I think that would be awesome. If we had both of those things, that would be another seismic change in how you write C++, I think. I think just reflection alone will be pretty
我觉得由于我们刚刚得出的原因，那样行不通。就像你想难倒他，或者你想提出一个“那如果……呢”，但从来没成功过，因为他把一切都想到了。嗯，当人们对一个话题有这种程度的熟悉度时，真的让人非常兴奋。总之，我不认为26年之前有任何可能实现这一点，但我真的很希望我们能在29年的时间框架内实现它。我觉得那会太棒了。如果我们拥有这两样东西，我的意思是，那将是编写C++方式的又一次颠覆性变革。我认为仅凭反射本身就会产生相当
impactful. If we get reflection in 26, it's going to make it a major release. I've been giving this talk, C++ Horizons, where I talk about the three things I'm most excited about and the future of C++. It's reflection, pattern matching, and senders. And I was so excited to see that we're making progress on reflection because it had seemed like it had been stalled for a while.
巨大的影响。如果我们能在26年引入反射，那它将成为一个重大版本。我一直在做一门名为《C++的远景》的演讲，在演讲中我谈到了我最期待的三件事以及C++的未来。它们是反射、模式匹配和发送器。我非常高兴地看到我们在反射方面取得了进展，因为之前它似乎停滞了一段时间。
And I was at – so I was in Switzerland a week or two ago going to, um, uh, to CERN to give, um, a couple of talks there. And I got to go see the particle accelerator underground, which was super, super cool. So many wires and they cut every wire to length. So there's like no extra slack in the wire. It's like they're, they designed this thing and then they're like, all right, we need a wire that's exactly this long. It's amazing.
我在——大概一两周前我在瑞士，去了趟欧洲核子研究中心（CERN）并在那里做了几场演讲。我有幸去地下参观了粒子加速器，真的酷毙了。里面有数不清的电线，而且每根电线都是按需裁剪长度的，所以几乎没有任何多余的松弛部分。感觉就像是他们设计好了这个东西，然后说：“行吧，我们需要一根刚好这么长的电线。”太神奇了。
We'll, um, we'll put some pictures on, uh, in the, in the show notes. Um, but when I was there, um, a group of the CERN folks, they scheduled a meeting for me and I thought it was just going to be like, let's talk about data layout and reflection and whatnot. But no, it was like 20 people from CERN and they had like a presentation and they were like, we want to convince you to care deeply about reflection and they were um they were talking about like their use case as a use case like i think a lot of people hear about reflection they're like oh that's cool like i can write the the function that convert that like you give it an enum and it gives me a string of what the enum's name is and that's the example it's used so often but um these cern folks they use reflection to optimize their data layout um and the the problem that they have is that they
我们会在……会在Shownotes（节目笔记）里放一些照片。不过我在那儿的时候，CERN的一群人专门为我安排了一个会议。我本来以为只是讨论一下数据布局（data layout）和反射（reflection）之类的事情，结果并不是。大概有20个来自CERN的人，他们做了一个演示，想说服我一定要高度重视反射。他们谈到了他们的用例，我觉得很多人听到反射时都会觉得：“哦，这挺酷的，我可以写个函数，传进去一个枚举（enum），它就能返回这个枚举名字的字符串。”这种例子实在太常见了。但是，CERN的这些家伙用反射来优化他们的数据布局。他们遇到的问题是……
got this giant particle accelerator machine and it just generates a ton of data just like tons and tons of data they have have like X bytes of data. You know, they're stored and they've got this throughput problem. And so they need to, you know, it's not always a like compute bottleneck or a latency bottleneck or a storage bottleneck,
他们拥有这个巨大的粒子加速器机器，它会产生海量的数据，真的是铺天盖地的数据，达到了艾字节（exabytes）级别。你知道的，这些数据需要存储，而且他们面临着吞吐量的问题。所以他们需要……这并不总是个计算瓶颈、延迟瓶颈或存储瓶颈，
but it's just a throughput bottleneck if we've got so much data and how do we process it and get it through? And one of the things that they've done in a lot of their experiments is they have some kludgy form of reflection where they can, in a certain place, they can switch from array of struct to struct of array, but they can also do things like, oh, hey, we have some technique where we can change the data layout to make this representation fit smaller in memory. So we can save like 40% memory usage. And like you actually, you see this a lot in a lot of other applications too. Like there's the, you know, there's like a GCC attribute for like packing your structs.
而纯粹是吞吐量瓶颈——面对这么多的数据，我们该怎么处理并让它们流通起来？他们在许多实验中采取的做法之一，就是使用某种笨拙的反射形式：在某些地方，他们可以从“数组结构体（array of struct）”切换到“结构体数组（struct of array）”，但他们还可以做一些事情，比如：“哦，嘿，我们有一种技术可以改变数据布局，让这种表示在内存中占用更小的空间。”因此我们可以节省大约40%的内存占用。其实你在许多其他应用程序中也能经常看到这一点。比如，你知道的，GCC有一个用于字节对齐/打包结构体（packing your structs）的属性（attribute）。
I know a lot of people use stuff like that. Like one of the really cool things we can do with reflection is we can build libraries that do all sorts of compile time optimizations of our, of our data types and our, and the layout of our data. And that can have such a huge impact. And like what they're doing today, they like have to use like compiler extensions or just like macros, just like piles of macros. And it sounds so painful.
我知道很多人都在用类似的东西。我们可以用反射来实现的最酷的事情之一，就是构建能够对我们的数据类型以及数据布局进行各种编译期优化的库。这会产生巨大的影响。而他们现在所做的事情，必须使用编译器扩展或者仅仅是宏——一大堆的宏。听起来就让人觉得痛苦。
And like this future where we have reflection, it's going to be great. It's going to be so much cleaner to do those things. One of the things that, so, you know, I have this expression type of library, YAP, it's part of Boost. And there are some severe limitations in what you can and cannot do because like you know essentially what you want to do with expression template libraries you want to capture some expression as uh you know a roll your own ast type and you can see all the pieces of it and then you have some transform that like walks the tree and does stuff, right? So if I had the reflection piece
而我们拥有反射的这个未来将会非常棒。做这些事情将会变得干净得多。其中一件事情是——我有这样一个表达式模板（expression template）库，叫YAP，它是Boost的一部分。你在其中能做什么、不能做什么有着很严苛的限制，因为你知道，本质上你想用表达式模板库做的事情是：把某个表达式捕获为一个……你知道的，自己编写的AST（抽象语法树）类型，你可以看到它的所有组成部分，然后你有一些遍历整棵树并执行操作的转换（transform），对吧？所以如果我有反射模块，
that fed into the pattern matching piece that then fed into the metaprogramming piece, I could write like the one expression template library to rule them all that would just supersede anything else, right? Like you could have one framework that said like, here's how you specify a transform. And the transform is just regular code because like the problem with doing transforms on asts is that you have to be
它能输入到模式匹配模块中，然后再输入到元编程模块中，我就可以写出“一个统治所有表达式模板库的终极库”，它将取代其他任何东西，对吧？你可以拥有这样一个框架：它说明了如何指定一个转换。而这个转换就是普通的常规代码，因为在AST上做转换的问题在于，你必须……
like oh i have to know what your funky node type is and all this stuff and i have to say like oh well i match this kind of case but if i don't match the exact kind of case i have to have like this loose loose matching and then what if i match the wrong thing because i uh there's a loose match that i was trying to hit but then i also hit this other one that i didn't want to hit and you know it gets really complicated really quickly. But if you could just write regular code that just says like, well, if this thing has such and such on the left and such and such on the right, then let me recurse. And then it's just normal code like with ifs and fors and stuff, then, oh, man, it's so much nicer. I like to think of that as it's the Louis Dion revolution in metaprogramming that we had, where it used to be that we would do all of our metaprogramming with this type-based metaprogramming that was like a completely different world than what we do today, which is where today we do value-based metaprogramming, as it's called, or like constexpr metaprogramming, where you could just write regular C++.
比如：“哦，我必须知道你那怪异的节点类型是什么之类的一大堆东西，我必须说：‘哦，好吧，我匹配了这种类型的情况，但如果我没有完全匹配这种类型的情况，我就得弄这种宽松的匹配。’然后万一我匹配错了怎么办？因为我本来想进行某种宽松匹配，结果却匹配到了我不想匹配的另一个东西。”你知道的，这很快就会变得非常复杂。但如果你能直接编写普通的常规代码，只说：“好吧，如果这个东西的左边是什么什么，右边是什么什么，那就让我递归。”然后这只是带有if和for之类的普通代码，噢天哪，那就好太多了。我喜欢把这看作是元编程领域的“路易·迪昂（Louis Dion）革命”：过去我们做所有元编程都使用基于类型的元编程（type-based metaprogramming），那是一个与我们今天完全不同的世界；而今天我们做的是基于值的元编程（value-based metaprogramming），或者叫constexpr元编程，你可以直接编写常规的C++。
And like, it's just regular C++ that's constexpr or constabout. And it's just so much, so much cleaner and so much better than how we used to, how we used to metaprogram. Yeah, yeah, totally. Well, I was just gonna say, I'm just really excited for it. Because like you said, it is like, if you think about before you could say if constexpr, right? What you had to do was like make a bunch of, make a struct that took template parameters and you had to have a bunch of partial specializations
而且它就是普通的C++，带有constexpr或consteval。比起我们过去做元编程的方式，它要干净得多、好得多。对，对，完全是这样。我刚才只是想说，我对它真的超级兴奋。因为正如你所说，这就好比——如果你回想一下在你可以使用if constexpr之前，对吧？你必须做的事情是：写一堆带有模板参数的结构体，你必须为那个结构体写一堆偏特化（partial specializations），
of that struct that some of them were, some of them win in this case versus that case. And so like, you know, I had this one thing inside of YAP that had five cases in it. It was a function that took a bunch of different kinds of things and then returned a common return or common sort of operation on those kinds of things and different return types.
其中有些在这种情况胜出，有些在那种情况胜出。所以，你知道的，我在YAP里面有这样一个东西，里面包含了五种情况。它是一个函数，接受各种不同类型的东西，然后返回一个通用返回值，或者对这些类型进行通用的某种操作并返回不同的返回类型。
So the way I wrote it first was using 17. I said if constexpr, some predicate, and then I changed these four alternatives after that. Those were the five cases, and it was easy peasy. Then I went back and did it for the 14 and earlier version, and I had to do this partial specialization thing where the right one, one in all five cases. And I mean, it's the kind of thing where when you're in it, you can write it.
所以我最初的写法是使用C++17。我说`if constexpr`，加上某个谓词（predicate），然后在这之后改变这四个分支。这就是那五种情况，非常简单轻松。后来我回头用C++14及更早版本重写了一遍，我不得不搞那种偏特化的东西，让正确的那一个在所有五种情况中胜出。我的意思是，这种事情就是：当你身处其中时，你还能写得出来；
And then when you look at it six months, you're like, I don't, I don't know why this works. I don't, I don't get why that specialization is better than that one. You know, like C++ is essentially just a series of complicated lookup systems glued together you've got like the the specialization engine you've got the overload engine you got a couple others and yeah like any time you have to write some some form of pattern matching or dispatching that relies on partial specialization or overload resolution
但当你过六个月再看它时，你会想：“我……我不知道这为什么能行。我……我不明白为什么那个特化比那个更好。”你知道的，C++本质上只是一系列复杂的查找系统粘合在一起。你有特化引擎（specialization engine）、重载引擎（overload engine），还有其他好几个引擎。所以，任何时候你不得不编写某种依赖于偏特化或重载决议的模式匹配或分发逻辑时，
it's like unless you're a real wizard, you're gonna have to go look up like, okay, like, why does this match versus like better than that? Whereas if you're just writing like traditional, like, you know, if else, like constructs, it's a lot, it's a lot simpler to figure out your logic, just by the simple case that if I've got like, you know, branched if-elses or, you know, pattern matching, the pattern matching proposal, its first match wins, right? So like, obviously you have to make sure that, you know, the things that you want to match, match, but it's not like overload resolution or partial specialization where it picks some priority and it's not necessarily in lexical order. Yeah. Yeah. You have to just have an overload set that works out. And that's what I was going to
除非你是个真正的魔法师，否则你都得去查阅文档：“好吧，为什么这个匹配比那个更好？”而如果你只是编写传统的、你知道的，类似if-else的结构，你的逻辑就要简单得多，仅仅因为一个简单的道理：如果我们有分支的if-else，或者模式匹配（模式匹配提案规定“首个匹配胜出”，对吧？），所以显然你必须确保你想匹配的东西能够匹配上，但它不像是重载决议或偏特化那样去挑选某种优先级，而且还不一定是按照字面顺序来的。对，对。你必须弄出一套能正常工作的重载集合。而这正是我接下来要说的……
say next is that like, this would take those if constexpr chains and turn them into regular ifs. So that's just, you know, it's not the same order of magnitude difference it was from like the old bad days of partial template specialization but it's better because like if constexpr is already kind of wonky right like if you don't if you don't have everything in an if else chain it doesn't work right like you can't have like the the typical pattern where you say like if something return early and then later on i just do the regular logic and return because now i have like if the predicate is true in the if constexpr now i've got two kinds of returns that might differ from each other.
我接下来要说的是，这会把那些`if constexpr`链变成普通的if。所以这虽然不像从前那些痛苦的模板偏特化时代那样有着数量级的巨大差异，但它还是更好，因为`if constexpr`本来就有点古怪，对吧？如果你没有把所有东西都放在一个if-else链里，它就无法正常工作。比如你不能写那种典型的模式：在某个条件满足时尽早返回（return early），然后在后面执行常规逻辑并返回——因为现在如果`if constexpr`里的谓词为真，我就有了两种可能彼此不同的返回类型。
So I have to have basically like an else. And that means I often have to repeat code in multiple places if I have if else, if context for else stuff nested. And just making a regular ifs is just great. You know, it's really amazing. So all that stuff I find super exciting. And I'm really looking forward to having it. But, you know, it's funny because we talk about these things and I'm like excited because this thing might make it in 29 it's like six years away at the earliest and yeah it's just the pace at which things happen
所以我基本上必须写一个else。这意味着如果我有嵌套的if-else或`if constexpr-else`之类的内容，我经常得在多个地方重复编写代码。而只要能写普通的if，那就太棒了。你知道的，这真的很神奇。所以我对所有这些东西都感到超级兴奋。我非常期待它的到来。但是，你知道的，这很有趣，因为我们在谈论这些事情时，我之所以兴奋，是因为这个东西可能会在C++29中实现——最早也要六年之后。所以，你知道的，事情发生的节奏就是这样……
speaking of you know c++ 29 and having to wait for pattern matching this whole time I've been waiting to ask Bryce would you like to revise what you said in our most popular episode of all time? If you ignore the first, you know, five or six, because those get more downloads. Episode 150, which we titled is C++ dying, I think just broke 5000 downloads. And usually we get like two to three within the first month anyway. So so I don't, if you look at our episodes, no episode breaks 5,000 since like the first few. And you famously said that you would be surprised if C++ ever shipped a major language feature. And now you're saying that it looks like in 26.
说到（你知道的）C++29以及不得不一直等待模式匹配，我憋了好久想问布莱斯（Bryce）：你愿意修正你在我们史上最受欢迎的那期节目中所说的话吗？如果你忽略前五六期的话，因为那些下载量更多。第150期节目，我们当时的标题是《C++正在消亡吗？》，我想下载量刚刚突破了5000次。通常无论如何我们在第一个月内也能获得两三千次下载。所以，如果你看一下我们的节目，除了最初的几期之外，没有哪期节目的下载量能突破5000次。而你当时极其著名地断言：如果C++能发布一个重大语言特性，你才会感到惊讶。但现在你却说，看起来它在26年……
But now you're saying it's likely that we'll get reflection in 26. So comments from Bryce 11 episodes later in episode 161. I don't think that the fact that this thing has surprised me and is likely to happen is indicative of... None of the systemic problems that I've highlighted with the C++ evolution problem have changed or been fixed. So, Bryce, aren't you concerned about your pants, like, getting caught in the gears when you backpedal so furiously? I mean, I think it's great that we'll get reflection. But I think that with a better evolution process, we would have gotten reflection a lot earlier.
但现在你说我们很有可能在26年获得反射。所以，对于在11期节目之后的第161期节目中，布莱斯的这些言论，你有什么要评论的吗？我不认为这个事情让我感到惊讶并且很有可能会发生，就说明……我之前指出的C++演进问题中的任何系统性问题得到了改变或修复。所以，布莱斯，当你如此疯狂地倒退/出尔反尔（backpedal）时，难道你不担心你的裤子被齿轮绞住吗？我的意思是，我认为我们能获得反射这很棒。但我觉得如果有一个更好的演进流程，我们早就该得到反射了。
I mean, the fact is that the proposal sat idle for two to three years and that everybody thought it was dead. And this is a programming language that millions and millions of people work on. We should have had a better process where we didn't just have like a long delay in work on that just because of the volunteer nature of our process and variety of other factors. So something occurred to me. This is actually – so Michael Park just got married and he brought his fiancée with him to the last meeting. And she was asking about – Yeah, yeah.
我的意思是，事实是这个提案闲置了了两到三年，所有人都以为它已经死了。而这是一个有数百万甚至数千万人在上面工作的编程语言。我们本应拥有一个更好的流程，而不是仅仅因为我们流程的志愿者性质以及其他各种因素，就在这项工作上经历如此漫长的延误。所以我想到了一个情况。这其实是——迈克尔·帕克（Michael Park）刚刚结婚了，他把未婚妻带到了最近的会议上。她当时在问关于——对，对。
He got married like last week, week before. Yeah. I did not know this. Yeah. And he – she was asking like some questions about the process and how we do things and she was just curious about it and and i i really you know i was explaining something to her and i had this kind of realization that you can only have when you explain to someone and you like step outside your normal frame of reference kind of like the stuff bear phenomenon where you explain to a co-worker like what your bug is and then you fix it you know in your head as you're explaining it so um she had asked something about like who who
他大概是一周前还是前周刚结的婚。对。我竟然不知道这事。对。然后他——她问了一些关于流程以及我们是如何做事的问题，她对此感到很好奇。而我——我真的，你知道的，当时在向她解释某些事情，然后我产生了一种只有当你向某人解释事情并跳出你平常的参考框架时才会有的顿悟——有点像“橡皮鸭现象”（rubber duck phenomenon），即你向同事解释你的bug是什么，然后在解释的过程中你就在脑海里把它修复了。所以，她当时问了一些关于“通常都是些什么人来参加这些会议？为什么是这些人在这里而不是其他C++程序员？是什么促使这个群体来参加会议？”之类的问题。然后我说：“嗯，我觉得很多人基本上都是志愿者，这有点像一个开源项目。”我说：“你知道，其他编程语言有资金充足的大型基金会，他们有人专门领着薪水致力于推动语言和标准库的发展之类的事情。我们没有那样的条件——我的意思是，我们确实有一小批人这样做，但这绝对是少数。”然后……
are the typical people that show up to these meetings? Like, why are these people here and not other C++ programmers? Like, what makes this group show up to the meetings? And I was like, well, I think a lot of people are kind of volunteers, and it's kind of like an open source project. And I said, you know, there's other programming languages that have big foundations that are well funded, and they have people that are like kind of paid to work on advancing the language in the standard library and stuff. We don't have that i mean we do have a cadre of people that does that but it's it's a minority for sure and um and then i said something that i had not thought of before maybe it's obvious to everyone else but i just realized this as i was saying it to her was
然后我说了一句我之前从未想过的话——也许对其他人来说这很明显，但我是在对她说的同时才意识到这一点的——那就是：“哦，我想我们之所以没有那种条件，是因为我们保证了向后兼容性（backwards compatibility）。”所以，当你保证了向后兼容性时，没有人需要关心你在语言中做什么。他们可以继续维持原状使用它。但如果你做一些类似于Python 2到Python 3那样的事情，如果这种可能性摆在桌面上，那么每个人都会派代表去委员会，大喊：“不要破坏我们需要用来工作的工具链！”对吧？所以，人们才会被允许——你知道的，我所在的公司有3000名C++程序员，而我是唯一一个去委员会的人，而且他们并没有付钱让我去。对吧？他们支持这样做，但这并不是我工作的一部分。对吧？他们不会安排任何人说：“去确保这个东西不会弄坏我们的代码”，因为他们知道代码不会坏，因为我们实际上不会做出破坏性的更改。所以这对我来说挺有意思的，对吧？最大的事情……
that like oh i think the reason why we don't have such a thing is that we guarantee backwards compatibility. And so when you guarantee backwards compatibility, no one has to care about what you're doing in the language. They can continue to use it as is. But if you do something like Python 2 to Python 3, and if that's on the table, then everyone is going to send someone to the committee and being like, don't break our tool chain that we need to do our work. Right. And so people, people are allowed, like, you know, I work at a company with 3000 C++ programmers and I'm the only one that goes to the committee and they don't pay me to do that. Right. Like they, they, they, they support it, but like, it's not part of my job. Right. They don't have anybody that they say like, go make sure that this thing doesn't break on us because they know it won't because we don't make breaking changes really. So that's kind of interesting to me, right? Like the big thing
阻止我们的演进向前发展的正是破坏——你知道的，不愿意破坏向后兼容性，在许多情况下甚至包括ABI兼容性。然而，这也许正是阻止人们在公司层面参与标准化流程（比如愿意支持人员去从事这项工作）的原因之一。所以，我们确实面临这样一个问题：这是一个开源项目，而任何开源项目都是靠人们想要做什么来决定生死。你知道的，如果没有人想去开发某个特定的特性，那么这个特性就根本不会被开发；如果有人精疲力竭了，那么这个特性就会消失。对吧？事情就是这样的。我以前从未想过这一点。对。所以，你知道的，如果你把这当作事实——如果有一天C++确实决定——比如说在C++32或35中，我们要搞一个像Python 2到Python 3那样的升级，即“这是你们将一堆特性塞进标准库的唯一一次机会”，你可以预料到，会有大量的人涌来参加那几次标准会议。
that prevents our evolution from moving forward is break is, you know, unwillingness to break backwards compatibility, including ABI compatibility in a lot of cases. And yet that's also maybe one of the things that keeps people from being engaged with the standardization process, like on a company level, like willingness to support people and go work on this stuff. So, you know, we really have this problem that it's an open source project and any open source project lives and dies by, you know, what people feel like working on. You know, if no one feels like working on a particular feature, then it just doesn't get worked on. And if someone gets burned out, then that feature goes away. Right. So that's just how it is. I had never thought about that. Yeah. So, you know, if, if you take that as like, you know, as that is, if at some point C++ does decide to have like you know in C++ 32 or 35 we are
我不认为我们想要一种基于恐惧的协作模型。这是一个有趣的观点。我以前从未想过这一点。我认为所有编程语言社区都有问题。显然，Python社区虽然很棒，
going to have like a Python 2 to 3 where like here's your one chance to get a bunch of features in you would expect that there's going to be like a huge uptick in the people like coming to those few standards meetings
我认为它很棒，但在许多方面它的运作要好得多。Python生态系统运作的许多方面都是我所羡慕的，我想我只能这么说。但他们也有他们自己的问题。再比如Rust，我也非常羡慕Rust生态系统的运作方式，而且我确实认为它比C++生态系统更好，但他们也遇到了一些问题，尤其是最近一段时间，有很多——我不会试图去弄清楚如何将这些成长中的烦恼（growing pains）分类，我觉得这完全可以归类为成长中的烦恼。对，这个说法很好。对，因为我的意思是，他们的……他们的社区规模正在呈爆炸式增长，对吧？
I don't think that we want to have a fear-based collaboration model. It's an interesting point. I had never thought about that before. I think all programming language communities have problems. Obviously, the Python community, while it's great,
这总是会带来问题。把新人纳入其中而不失去自己的文化是很难的。但我不知道——我不知道——我认为向后兼容性是悬在我们头顶的一把剑。但我认为更多人没有参与进来的真正原因在于，决策速度太慢了，流程也太晦涩难懂了，这把大家挡在了门外。而且，你知道的，对任何人或公司来说，决定进行长达10年的投资是很困难的。我认为实际上向后兼容性问题是它如此缓慢的一个重要部分，特别是对于语言演进而言。对于库演进，你只需把东西往墙上一扔，看哪个能粘在墙上就行了。
I think it's great, I think is run a lot better in many ways. There are many things about the way the Python ecosystem operates that I'm envious of, I think is the way I would say. But they've had their share of problems. Rust, again, I think very envious of how the Rust ecosystem ecosystem works and i do think it's better than the cepa specific system but they've also had some problems especially more recently um there's been a lot of uh i'm not going to try to figure out how to classify growing pains i think it's categorized categorizable as growing pains yeah good way to put it yeah because i mean their their their um community is exploding in science, right?
我们在库里塞了大量的东西。然后过几个版本后，我们就会说：“嗯，我们不再需要这个了。”但对于语言来说，你一旦把它放进去，你就和它结婚了。你永远无法把它从语言中移除。有一个重大的反例是基本上从来没有人实现过，所以我们可以把它划掉，那就是`export`以及其他所有东西——你知道的，不是模块的`export`，而是旧的`export`，模板的`export`。对，所以……
And that's always problematic. And, you know, just bringing new people into the fold and not losing your culture is hard. But I'm not sure if – I'm not sure if the – I think that the backwards compatibility is something that hangs over our head. But I think that the real reason that more people don't get involved is that the decision making is so slow and the process is so arcane that it sort of keeps people away. And, you know, it's hard for any person or company to decide on a 10-year investment. I think really like the backwards compatibility issues are a big part of why it's so slow, especially for language evolution. For library evolution, you just throw it against the wall and see what sticks.
无论如何，你知道的，但我认为你说的对。就像当你告诉别人——嘿，你知道的，过去经常有人来找我，对吧？然后说：“嘿，为什么这个不能这样工作？”然后我说：“去写一篇论文（paper）吧，我可以帮你的。”然后他们说：“好的。”然后——然后情况就变成了：“是的，然后你需要去开会，或者我可以为你做提案冠军（champion it）。”然后当他们带着意见回来时，比如你需要解决这些意见等等。这让人望而生畏。人们就会说：“这太令人畏惧了，我才不干呢，这太夸张了。”是的，这确实要干很多工作。而且整个——你知道的，我一直都是这种观点的坚定支持者：一方面，我们有所有这些ISO流程和程序，它们非常晦涩难懂；但另一方面，仅在委员会内部，就有很多……
We put a lot of stuff in the library. Then a couple of revisions later, we're like, yeah, we don't need this anymore. But with language, you put it in there and you're married to that. You're never going to get that out of the language. There's one major counterexample that basically no one ever implemented. So we could strike it, which was export and everything else like, you know, not modules export, the old export, the template export. Yeah. So, yeah.
为什么我们要给研究小组（study groups）编号呢？如果你是这个流程的新手，比如SG 25或SG 27，对一个新人来说这根本没有任何意义。好吧，即使在圈内人当中也是如此。我曾提及过SG9，结果别人问：“那是哪个来着？”就像那是ranges（范围）那个小组。他们会说：“哦，对，对，SG9。太好了。”我在担任库演进主席时曾做出巨大努力，绝不使用研究小组的编号。我总是把名字完整地打出来。
Anyway, you know, but I think what you're saying is right. Like it's when you tell someone, hey, you know, people have come to me in the past, right? And said, like, hey, why doesn't this work like this? And I'm like, write a paper, I can help you. And like, okay. And then, and then it's like, yeah, so then you need to go to a meeting, or I can champion it for you. And then when they come back with comments, like you need to, you know, address those comments, and so on. And like, it's daunting. And people are like,'s daunting and people are like yeah i'm not gonna i'm not gonna do all this this is too much right yes yeah it's it's a lot of work and and the whole you know and i i'm always big proponent of this like one you know we have all this iso process and procedure which is very arcane but then like just just within the committee there's plenty of um uh there's just it's it's too insular in many ways like like
对，这是一个好的政策。老实说，我觉得对论文编号（paper numbers）也应该这样，因为不，我甚至记不住我自己的论文编号，对吧？是的，论文编号……所以，现实情况就是，这个流程——演进流程并不是真正设计出来的，它只是一种我们从未坐下来思考过的东西：“我们应该如何构建C++演进，才能让它具有可持续性、能够壮大委员会、能够应对委员会规模的扩大、能够设定方向、做出决策？”我们从来没有坐下来开会讨论过该如何做到这一点。
why why do we have to number the study groups if you're new to the process like sg 25 or 27 like yeah that that has no meaning to to to an. Well, even among insiders. I have referred to SG9 and people are like, which one is that again? Like that's the ranges one. They're like, oh, yeah, right, SG9. Okay, great. I made a big effort when I was chairing library evolution to never use the study group numbers. I would always type out the names.
它只是变成了一种这种临时凑合（ad hoc）的东西。我认为这导致了很多问题。最重要的是，这里还有很多基础设施问题，并且受到ISO流程的很多基础设施问题和限制。所以，反射看起来很有可能会实现，这并没有改变我对我们整体流程问题的看法。我认为反射将是一个“不顾我们现有的问题而最终获得成功的特性”的故事。而且我也确信，从现在到反射正式发布之间，还会有一定数量的阻碍、戏剧性和问题，并且其中至少有一部分将是由我们流程的局限性所导致的。
Yeah, that's a good policy. I think the same with paper numbers, honestly, too because no i don't have my own papers numbers right i'm yeah paper numbers yeah yeah and so just like like you know the reality is that the process the evolution process wasn't really designed it's just sort of a thing that like we we never sat down and thought like how should we structure c++ evolution to be sustainable, to grow the committee, to be able to handle growing the committee, to be able to set direction, make decisions. We never sat down and had a meeting about how to do that.
对。而且事情是这样的，这确实导致了我们在委员会中经常出现的一种情况，那就是大量的“小调整”（little tweaks），对吧？因为小调整是一些唾手可得的小块内容，你可以说：“哦，我不喜欢那个。我可以修复它。让我为此写一篇论文。”
It's just sort of been like this ad hoc thing. And I think that's led to a lot of problems. And on top of that, there's just a lot of infrastructure problems, and there's a lot of infrastructure problems and limitations from the ISO process. And so the fact that reflection looks likely to happen doesn't change my opinion on our overall process issues. I think reflection is going to be the story of a feature that succeeds in spite of the problems that we have. And also, I'm sure that between now and when reflection ships, there will be some amount of holdups and drama and problems, and at least some of them will be caused by the limitations of our process.
然后你写了一篇论文，大家就会说：“哦，我看到这里有个问题。我们修复它吧。”然后你的东西通过了，你就完成了。你接着处理下一件事情。这很整洁。然后你会遇到像ranges（范围）这样耗费了埃里克·尼布勒（Eric Niebler）好几年生命的东西，你知道的。如果你愿意这样做并坚持到底，那么它最终确实会有所回报。但当我说是“耗费了他的生命”时，我是说真的——在很长一段时间里，他除了做这个什么都不做。而且，甚至在职业生涯方面，他一度甚至把这作为他的全职工作。所以，你知道的，完全是这样。所以他真的是——全力投入进去了，对吧？而且，还有其他人，比如你——我不知道戈尔（Gore）有多少时间被协程（coroutine）的事情垄断了，但从他写论文的时间跨度来看，这绝对花了很长时间。这需要某种特定类型的人。我的意思是，我觉得我们有一群自我筛选得非常厉害的人，比如C++程序员整体而言，
Yeah. Yeah, and the thing is that this really leads to something that we have a lot in the committee, which is like little tweaks, right? Because a little tweak is some of the bite-sized, you can be like, oh, I don't like that. I could fix that. Let me write a paper for that.
他们非常习惯于延迟满足，因为这就是作为一个C++程序员的意义所在。但对大多数人来说，这是有极限的，而且对大多数人来说，这个极限远短于六年。对，对。我的意思是，我觉得——也许这对任何语言来说都是真的。我的意思是，我觉得——也许这对任何语言来说都是真的，也许如果你想在Python中推动某个大型特性，它花的时间也会比你预期的要长。但我的印象是，我们……我们的行动速度慢得独树一帜。
And you write a paper for it, and people are like, yeah, I see there's a problem. Let's fix that. And then your thing goes through and you're done. You move on to the next thing. And it's nice and tidy. And then you've got something like ranges, which took over Eric Kneebler's life for like, you know, years. And if you're willing to do that and stick with it, then it does pay off in the end. But like when I say took over his life, I mean, for real, like he was just doing nothing but this for a very long time. And, you know, in terms of even professionally, like he was at one point, working on it as his day job, even. So like, you know, exactly. So he was, you know, really like all in on it, right. And, you know, there's other people like, you like – I don't know how much of Gore's time was monopolized by Covertine stuff, but it definitely was a long time getting it from – if you look at the timeframe in which he was writing papers, it took a certain kind of person. I mean, I think we have a pretty self-selected group of people, like C++ programmers in general,
慢得离谱。对，对。我想我——我几天前向PyCon提交了一个演讲，题为《Python的力量》（The Power of Python），这个演讲的重点基本上是想说，我认为Python是提高生产力最好的编程语言。NVIDIA——NVIDIA未必会用Python从头到尾编写一堆各种编译器栈，但既然我现在从事研究工作，我基本上几乎所有事情都用Python做。如果我想写C++代码，我会写Python来帮我生成C++代码。我用Python可以行动得如此之快，不仅是语言本身，还包括它周围的生态系统。而且它现在处于这样一种境遇：
who are very comfortable with the delayed gratification because that's what it means to be a C++ programmer. But there's limits to that for most people, and the limits are far shorter than six years for most people. Yeah, yeah. I mean, I think that's, you know, maybe that's true of any language. i mean i think that's you know maybe that's true of any language maybe it's the case if you want to do some drive some big feature in python it's going to take longer than you expect but um my my my impression is that uh we um we move uniquely
富者愈富，因为大语言模型（LLM）在生成Python代码方面表现得最好，因为现有的Python代码语料库太庞大了。而且，有一点很值得一提——你刚才说“C++程序员能够接受延迟满足，因为我们一直在与编译器搏斗，等待代码编译”，这让我立刻想到了这一点。而在Python中，情况恰好相反。
slow slowly yeah yeah i think i uh i submitted a talk to pycon just a couple days ago called the power of python uh which is the point of the talk is to basically say that i think python is like the best programming language for being productive like nvidia nvidia is not necessarily gonna ship a bunch of whatever compiler stacks written top to bottom in python but now that i'm in research i basically do almost everything in python like i want to write c++ code i'll write python to write me my c++ code like i i can move so fast with python and not just not just the language but like the ecosystem around it yeah um and also it's in this situation now where like Python is in a,
虽然你可能第一次没有把代码写对，但那种写下代码、按下一个按钮、事情马上就运行起来的感觉实在是太美妙了。对，对。而且——我有时会感到沮丧，我自诩是个ranges专家，然后我试图去写一些我声称自己能在三分钟内搞定的代码。我在周五的会议上说过这话：“给我三分钟，我就能把ranges代码搞定。”结果40分钟后，我还卡在那儿。我当时就想：
like a state where the rich are going to get richer because LLM models, they do best at like generating Python code. Cause the corpus of Python code is so large out there. And there's something to be said about like, like you, you made me think of this exact when you said like C++ programmers are okay with delayed gratification. Cause we're constantly fighting with the compiler and waiting things for to compile and with python it's the exact
“哦，对。GCC 13.2没有实现ranges。微软MSVC有一个实现上的问题无法工作，你需要在Compiler Explorer（Godbolt）上使用一个宏才能使用它。”
opposite of that like sure maybe you didn't write it correctly the first time but like it's just so nice to like write code hit a button and things are running um yeah yeah and uh and like i just i get frustrated sometimes like i'm supposedly a ranges expert and then i'm trying to write some code that i said I could get working in three minutes. I said this in a meeting on Friday and I was like, give me three minutes and I'll have the ranges code 40 minutes later. I've like,
然后我转向了我写的一个内部工具，从标准ranges放弃，转而使用range-v3，终于弄出了点能运行的东西。当时我就忍不住爆粗口：“搞什么鬼？开会期间花了40分钟！”而在我脑海里，
Oh yeah. GCC 13.2 doesn't implement ranges. Colon colon two MSVC, uh, has some implementation thing that doesn't work and you need a macro to use it on God book, you know, compiler Explorer.
这本该是三分钟就能搞定的事。对，对。这其实一直是我对概念（concepts）的最大抱怨：标准库和ranges中的概念的主要用例，我们在添加新事物时才开始把它们加进去。但基本上，随着概念约束（concept constraints）而来的唯一一大块工作就是ranges里的那些东西。
And like, then I went to this internal tuba I had written, like went away from standard ranges to this range of E3 finally got something working. And I was just like, what the heck? Like 40 minutes during a meeting. And I,
好吧，每当我试图使用它时，如果出了问题，我就会想：“现在该怎么办？”我的意思是，我——你知道的，我是那种专家级别的C++模板老油条，如果我拿到一个巨大无比的模板实例化栈，我能调试它，我能找出概念到底出了什么问题。但通常很大程度上取决于我正在使用的是哪个编译器。用Clang的话，我会得到这样一连串错误：“这个概念检查失败了，因为这个子概念检查失败了，因为这个失败了，因为这个……”因为这里有一个漂亮的链条。而在GCC上，它的表现就像是：“嘿，这破玩意儿坏了，伙计。你自己看着办吧。”MSVC也是一样，
in my head, it should have, should have been like a three minute thing. Yeah. Yeah. That's been my big gripe actually with, with concepts is that, you know, the, the major use case for concepts in the standard libraries and the ranges stuff, we're starting to add them to new things as we add them. But basically the only big chunk of work that came in with concept constraints was the stuff in ranges.
它们的诊断信息真的很烂。而且有一些技术原因（我并不是完全理解）导致我们得到的这个版本的概念很难编写好的诊断信息。大家在标准化它时其实非常担心这一点，而旧版本的概念则能带来好得多的诊断信息。再说一次，我不记得具体的技术原因了，但我记得当时它的卖点。如果你看一下道格·格雷戈尔（Doug Gregor）早期的原型，他当时在演讲中展示了你会得到什么：
Well, whenever I try to use it, if there's a problem, I'm like, now what? Like, I mean, I'm, you know, i'm an expert level sql slisper guy where if i get a big huge template instantiation stack i could i could debug that like i could figure out what the problem is with the concepts often it's very very much depends on which implementation i'm using with with clang i get this like this concept check failed because this subconcept check failed because this one failed because and this because there's a nice chain of them. And with GCC, it's like, hey, shit's broke, man. Like, no, you go. And it's the same way with MSVC, too.
来自某人书中的一个经典的过时模板示例，人们以前经常引用这个例子——你知道的，让我调用`std::sort`，但我对一个链表（list）调用它，对吧？——所以我对我的链表`l`调用`std::sort`，我调用`sort(l.begin(), l.end())`，然后我得到了一条奇怪的消息，深入到`sort`算法本身的底层内部，说：“嘿，这一行说不通。”我就想：“为什么这一行说不通？”然后，道格·格雷戈尔的原型实现——旧版本的概念，C++11之前的概念（ox版本）——它会说：“这行不通，因为这是错误的迭代器类别（iterator category）。”当时的感觉就是：“对，对！这正是我们想要的。我们想要它说：‘这是你代码的高层问题，修复方法就是：你根本不能对它进行排序，也许你应该看看有没有成员函数`sort`。结果证明是有的，你应该改用那个。’”这真的太酷了。而现在，如果你做同样的例子，我敢肯定它给你的错误信息跟你以前用无约束模板（unconstrained templates）时得到的差不多。
Like, they just don't have very good diagnostics. And there are some technical reasons I don't fully understand for why the version of concepts that we got is hard to write diagnostics for. And people are really worrying about this when we're standardizing it, whereas the old one lent itself to much better diagnostics. And again, I don't remember the technical reasons why, but I remember the selling point. You know, if you look at Doug Greger's early prototype and he was giving talks like, here's what you get,
也就是说，它给你的是一堆乱七八糟的答案，解释为什么`std::ranges::sort`无法工作，但它不会给你这种高层面的解释：“这就是需要改变你代码的地方，这样才能让它工作。”甚至不仅是为了让它工作，而是“这就是为什么这行不通”。我觉得这真的很可悲。事实上，我——你知道的，我写的很多代码都是为了Boost。所以，我用概念约束编写的很多代码，实际上都加上了这样的逻辑：如果使用概念，这里是带有概念的模板头；
like the famous example of an l-form template from like someone's book that people used to refer to a lot was uh you know let me call stood sort but i'm calling it on a list on like a stood list right uh so i'm calling stood uh you know for my list l i'm calling uh sort l dot begin l dot end and i get some weird message that's like way down the bowels of like the sort algorithm itself saying like hey this is this doesn't you know make sense this line and i'm like why doesn't this make sense and then you know doug gregor's prototype implementation the old version of concepts the ox version of concepts before 11 um it said like this doesn't work because that is the wrong iterator category and it was like yeah yeah that's what that's what we want we wanted to say like this
否则，这里是那个有问题的模板，然后重新编译，这样我才能得到那堆我必须去啃的、庞大的模板实例化垃圾错误信息，因为我懂得如何处理那种错误。我的意思是，这并不是我们想要的——这不是我们想要达到的状态。这绝不是一个好的现状。对，这太悲哀了。你能看到我的屏幕吗？呃-huh。等等，我分享的是正确的内容吗？没有。你看到Godbolt的链接了吗？
is the high level problem with your code and this the fix is like you just can't sort that maybe you should look and see if there's a member sort turns out there is and you should use that instead right so that was really cool and then now if you if you do the same example i'm pretty sure it gives you something along the lines of what you used to get with just unconstrained templates that is to say it gives you a a big mess of of an answer for why like std ranges sort doesn't work um but it doesn't um it doesn't give you this high level thing of like this is the thing that changed your code to make this work or not even just to make it work but this is why this won't work um i i feel like that's really sad and in fact i have um you know a lot of the code that I write is for Boost. And so like a lot of stuff that I've been writing with concept constraints, I've actually been putting like if use concepts, here's the template head with the concepts in it.
没有，我只看到一些关于Aspire休息室（Aspire Lounge）的内容。哦，我分享错屏幕了。稍等。看起来像是对的。我还以为你是想特意告诉康纳（Connor）他应该去别的休息室之类的地方呢。我的意思是，现实情况是康纳可能根本……我还以为你是想特意告诉康纳他应该去别的休息室之类的地方呢。我当时还在想：这对话要走向何方？现实情况是康纳可能根本没有权限进入任何更好的休息室。噢，布莱斯真是个精致的人。他想让每个人都知道这一点。
And then else here's the template that's got a problem and then recompile so that I can get the massive spew of template instantiation crap that I'm supposed to dig through because that I understand how to work with. I mean, that's not what we want to – that's not where we want to be. That's not a good state of affairs. Yeah, that's very sad. Can you see my screen? Uh-huh. Wait, am I sharing the right thing? No. Do you see the Godbolt link?
布莱斯刚说完那话，我就想：好戏开场了。扎克（Zach）马上要压他一头了。好了，让我们看看GCC在这里会不会表现好一点。我们正在看的是：当你对一个链表调用`std::ranges::sort`时，你会得到什么诊断信息？通常我不会允许布莱斯共享屏幕，但今天是节日特辑，所以今天我们想干嘛就干嘛。
No, I just see something about the Aspire Lounge. Oh, I shared the wrong one. Hang on. It looked like it was the right one. I thought you were going to pointedly tell Connor he should be in a different lounge or something. I mean, the reality is Connor probably doesn't were going to pointedly tell Connor he should be in a different lounge or something. I was like, where's this going? The reality is Connor probably doesn't have access to any of the better lounges. Oh, Bryce is fancy. He wants everyone to know it.
我允许了。谢谢你，康纳。所以，布莱斯，我看到你背景里有一棵可爱的光明节灌木（Hanukkah bush）。是的，是的。嗯，我女朋友的妈妈和12岁的侄女明天就要从她们那儿——从波兰抵达了。她们两个都不会说英语。所以这将会——而且她们要在这里待两周，所以这将会——而且她们要在这里
As soon as Bryce said that, I was like, here we go. Zach's about to take him down a bit. All right, let's see if GCC is any better here. We're looking at what is the diagnostic that you get from the calling stood range of sort on a list. Usually I wouldn't allow Bryce to screen share, but this is the holiday special, so we're doing whatever we want today.
待两周，这将会非常有趣。我看到了你发的那条推文，我太喜欢了——回复你推文的人中大约有10%总是变着法子难为你。其中一个人说：“看布莱斯在含蓄地炫耀他有女朋友的事。”我有女朋友的父母，这很平常（NBD），你知道的。所以我想我的祖母云云……我想公平地说，我们还需要看看……你会得到什么？也许我们应该在一个单独的Godbolt窗口中做这个。如果你不用ranges会发生什么？是的，就只说`std::sort`，对。所以，我其实没有时间去读它。
I'll allow it. Thank you, Connor. So, Bryce, I see you have a lovely Hanukkah bush in the background. Yes, yes. Well, I have my girlfriend's mother and 12-year-old niece are arriving tomorrow from Poland. Neither of them speak any English. So it's going to be, and they're going to be here for two weeks so it's going to be and they're going to
我当时正试图把它放大。我忙着嘲笑你，根本没空仔细阅读代码。它在这里对我们说了什么？好吧，所以GCC告诉我们这是我们调用的东西。还有，等等，在我们诊断错误之前，能不能先为听众解释一下我们刚才写了什么代码？是的，有很多需要解释的地方。安静点，安静点。所以我们写了一段代码：我们创建了一个存储int的`std::list`，然后我们直接对它调用了`std::ranges::sort`。
be here for two weeks it's going to be a ton of fun uh i saw that tweet you sent out and i love i love that like 10 of people that reply to your tweets are always just giving you a hard time and my one one person said look at bryce breaking up about the fact that he's got a girlfriend subtly i have a girlfriend parents nbd you know so i suppose my grandmother blah blah i suppose to be fair we would need to also look at um what do you get and maybe we should do that in a separate GodBalt window. What happens if you do this without ranges? Yeah, just say std sort, yeah. Yeah. So I didn't really have time to read it.
在这里待两周，那会非常有趣。呃，我看到了你发的那条推文，我喜欢——我喜欢回复你推文的人里总有10%的人在找你麻烦。其中一个人说，看布莱斯在含蓄地炫耀他有女朋友的事实。我有女朋友了，父母，没什么大不了的，你知道的。所以我想我祖母……等等。我觉得公平起见，我们还需要看看……嗯，你得到了什么，也许我们应该在一个单独的GodBalt窗口里做这件事。如果不使用ranges会发生什么？是的，就用std sort，是的。好吧，所以我其实没时间读它。
I was trying to make it bigger. I was too busy laughing at you to carefully read the code. What is it saying to us here? Okay, so GCC tells us this is what we're calling. Also, wait, can we explain for the listener the code we've written first before we diagnose the error? Yeah, there's much to explain. Pipe down, pipe down. So we've got code where we just create a std list of int, and then we just call std ranges sort on it.
我刚才正试图把它弄大点。我刚才忙着笑话你，没仔细读代码。它在这里对我们说了什么？好的，GCC告诉我们这就是我们正在调用的函数。还有，等等，在我们诊断错误之前，能不能先向听众解释一下我们写好的代码？是的，有很多需要解释的。安静，安静。所以我们写了一段代码，在其中我们只是创建了一个std::list，然后我们在上面调用了std::ranges::sort。
And it should not compile because sort requires a random access range, and list does not provide bidirectional iterators. So with GCC, it tells us, well, no match for call to this function. But of course, the function that you're trying to call is one of these sort customization point objects. So it says no match for call to, and then there's a call expression for std ranges, colon, colon, underscore, underscore, sort, underscore function. So the fact that we didn't, that this thing's a function object and that we don't have a better way of doing the customization points at the time that we ship ranges shows in the diagnostic.
而且它不应该通过编译，因为sort需要一个随机访问范围（random access range），而list并没有提供双向迭代器。所以在GCC中，它告诉我们，嗯，没有与此函数调用相匹配的函数。但当然，你试图调用的函数是这些sort定制点对象（customization point objects）之一。所以它说没有与……相匹配的调用，然后这里有一个针对std ranges::colon::colon::underscore::underscore::sort::underscore function的调用表达式。所以，事实上我们没有……这个东西是一个函数对象，而且在我们发布ranges时，我们没有更好的方法来处理定制点，这一点在诊断信息中表现出来了。
And then it shows the overload set that it tried, which is the call. This is all the candidate functions, yeah. Yeah, but this is the call operator for this function object. So somebody who doesn't understand how it just works under the hood, I think could be quite confused by this. You know, like a naive user, I'm being literal here, would look at this and say like, oh, sort is a macro or something. Because they see it transliterated into doubles underscore sort fun.
然后它显示了它尝试过的重载集合，也就是调用。这包含了所有的候选函数，是的。是的，但这是针对这个函数对象的调用运算符。所以，如果不理解它是如何在底层工作的人，我认为可能会对此感到非常困惑。你知道，就像一个新手用户——我在这里说的是字面意思——会看着这个然后说，哦，sort是一个宏或者别的什么。因为他们看到它被直译为了双下划线sort fun。
And they're like, oh, well well that's not what i call it so this must be like substituting a thing for another thing and i don't know what's going on here so one of these here so so a bunch of them say constraints not a bunch of these so it says she didn't match any overload here's all the ones i tried and um i see at least one that says constraint's not satisfied, but it doesn't say why the constraint wasn't satisfied. No, no, no. Okay, right here. If you go down, it does. Yeah.
然后他们会想，哦，嗯，这可不是我调用的名字，所以这一定是用一个东西替代了另一个东西，我不知道这里发生了什么，所以这里有这些……所以其中有很多都显示“约束不满足”，这里有好多……所以它说没匹配到任何重载，下面是我尝试过所有的重载，嗯……我看到至少有一个说“约束未满足”，但它没有说明为什么约束没有满足。不，不，不。好的，就在这里。如果你往下看，它确实说明了。是的。
So we got one that says requires random access range. Oh, that's actually pretty nice. Yeah. Yeah. But that was in the middle of the diagnostic. It took us a little bit. Yeah. You have to read down several error and note lines to get to that. Yeah. So there is also down here, it says, this is below the failed call. There's something where it says, I think this is where it's digging into why this requirement failed.
所以我们找到了一个显示“需要随机访问范围”的错误。哦，这其实相当不错。是的。是的。但那是诊断信息的中间部分。我们花了点时间才找到。是的。你必须向下阅读好几行错误和提示信息才能找到那个。是的。所以下面这里也有，它说，这是在失败的调用下面。有些内容说，我想这就是它在深入探讨为什么这个要求没有得到满足的地方。
So it's a call stack and it starts off by saying required for the satisfaction of something derived from some concept and then required for the satisfaction of random access iterator. And then eventually like the last part of the diagnostic says std random access iterator tag is not a base of std bidirectional iterator tag. Okay. The clang one is a little bit better because the clang one, it also has no matching function for call to object of type underscore underscore sort fn. But then it's got a cleaner list of the overloads that tried and failed.
所以它是一个调用栈，开头说“需要满足某个派生自某个概念的东西”，然后是“需要满足随机访问迭代器”。最后，诊断信息的最后一部分说，std::random access iterator tag不是std::bidirectional iterator tag的基类。好吧。Clang的诊断信息要稍微好一点，因为Clang的也有“对类型为__sort_fn的对象调用没有匹配的函数”，但它有一个更清晰的重载列表，展示了它尝试过但失败的函数。
And the second one there, or maybe it's the first one. Yeah, it's the first one. The first one says candidate template ignored, constraints not satisfied. And then the next line, it says, because std list int reference does not satisfy random access range.
那里的第二个，或者也许是第一个。对，是第一个。第一个说，候选模板被忽略，约束未满足。然后下一行说，因为std::list::reference不满足随机访问范围。
This is what I was talking about when I said, like, I think the Clang diagnostics are way better than MSVC or GCC for concepts right now. Like, this is very nice, right? It says, it just shows you the function. It quotes the line. And then it says, this candidate template does not work because of lack of constraint satisfaction. And then the next line is why, in a way that you can understand immediately.
这就是我之前说的，我觉得现在对于概念来说，Clang的诊断信息比MSVC或GCC好得多。比如，这非常好，对吧？它说，它直接向你展示了函数。它引用了那行代码。然后它说，这个候选模板无法工作，因为缺乏约束满足。接下来的原因则以一种你能立刻理解的方式呈现出来。
There's still the noise of, like, double underscore sort fun and that kind of stuff but you know that's that's fine if if the rest of the the experience is that nice but i gotta say like this is a pretty yeah i was gonna say like write it out um with begin and end instead of just passing an l i think they get worse and the thing is that these are both pretty easy cases like if you do anything more complicated with concepts where like the failure isn't at like the top level the identity of the thing like you know it has to have like bi-directional range is like i think what you write instead of a type name range or bi-directional r instead of type name r and so it's like at the top level you have a failure but if your failure is like oh well it's like it meets bi-directional range but there's like at the top level you have a failure. But if your failure is like, oh, well, it's like it meets bidirectional range,
这里仍然有一些噪音，比如双下划线sort_fun诸如此类的事情，但你知道，如果其余的体验都这么好，那也没问题。不过我得说，这真是个相当……我本来想说，如果用begin和end来写，而不是只传一个l，我觉得它们会变得更糟。关键是，这些都还算简单的例子：如果你用概念做一些更复杂的事情，比如失败不是发生在顶级，也就是事物的身份上——你知道，它必须具备类似“双向范围”的东西，就像我猜你会用它来代替typename range，或者用bi-directional r来代替typename r，所以这就像你在顶级遇到了失败。但如果你的失败是，哦，好吧，它符合双向范围……但如果你的失败是，哦，好吧，它符合双向范围，
but there's like a requires that like something about the value type has to look a certain way or something like this somewhere. And then you go finally all the way down into the guts of the thing and you dereference the iterator and then it gives you a value type or a reference type if you dereference an iterator. It gives you a reference type that looks wrong. Then that kind of error message is way way worse um you know the the sort of the higher in the structural um matching you're doing on the concept like the higher that it fails like the better the error message is the more it has to go down into it the worse the story is for the diagnostics so so the the free, pre-concepts diagnostic that you get here in both GCC and Clang, it basically tells you that there's no operator minus for your stood list iterator.
但某处有一个requires子句，规定关于值类型的东西必须长成某种特定形状。然后你最终深入到它的内部，对迭代器进行解引用，如果你对迭代器解引用，它就会给你一个值类型或引用类型。它给出的引用类型看起来不对。那么这种错误信息就会变得极其糟糕……你知道的，你在概念上进行的结构匹配越高阶——它失败得越早，错误信息就越好；它必须深入到底层的程度越深，诊断信息的表现就会越糟糕。所以，GCC和Clang中原有的、在引入概念之前的诊断信息，基本上会告诉你，你的std::list迭代器没有operator minus。
This is the whole point of concepts is that it's meant to, you know, check requirements before you go and, you know, instantiate the body of the thing. And so like, obviously, like the underlying problem here is like, okay, well, the list iterator doesn't have operator minus because it's not a random access iterator. And the algorithm assumes that it's a random access that you need to pass a random access iterator and the algorithm assumes that um that it's a random access that you need to pass a random access iterator to it so you know this i think this diagnostic almost certainly is worse because oh yeah it doesn't at any point tell you that hey i needed a random access thing yeah the fact that the names bidirectional and random access never appear anywhere in here. You just have to know that, oh, operator minus
这就是概念的全部意义所在，它旨在（你知道的）在你去实例化函数体之前检查各项要求。所以很明显，这里的根本问题在于：好吧，list迭代器没有operator minus，因为它不是一个随机访问迭代器。而算法假定它是一个随机访问迭代器，你需要向它传递一个随机访问迭代器，算法假定……你需要向它传递一个随机访问迭代器，所以你知道，这个诊断信息几乎可以肯定是更糟糕的，因为——哦，对，它在任何地方都没有告诉你“嘿，我需要一个随机访问的东西”。事实上，名称“双向（bidirectional）”和“随机访问（random access）”在这里根本没有出现过。你只能自己去推断，哦，operator minus
is defined on random access iterators, but not the ones I gave it. There's a lot of inference you have to do. It's also worth noting that in both of these diagnostics, you have internal names. Even though std sort is not a customization point object, it's not like one of these function objects, this diagnostics that we get here,
是在随机访问迭代器上定义的，而不是我给它的那种。你必须进行大量的推理。同样值得注意的是，在这两种诊断信息中，你都会看到内部名称。尽管std::sort并不是一个定制点对象，它不属于那种函数对象，但我们在这里得到的诊断信息，
it still shows the error manifests in std colon colon underscore underscore sort. And it's not std colon colon list colon colon iterator. It's std colon colon underscore capital list iterator. So there's still a lot of implementation details that get exposed. Yeah. Yeah. I suppose we should, sometime we should have Eric
错误仍然表现为出现在std::colon::colon::__sort中。而且它也不是std::colon::colon::list::colon::iterator。它是std::colon::colon::__list_iterator。所以仍然有大量的实现细节被暴露了出来。是啊。是啊。我想我们应该找个时间让Eric
on this podcast and ask him, hey, what's up? How do better? My understanding is that this is, that the language feature itself is kind of to blame for this, not the ranges implementation, not the approach that they chose for ranges. That's my understanding.
来上这个播客，问问他：“嘿，怎么回事？怎么才能做得更好？”据我理解，导致这种情况的是语言特性本身，而不是ranges的实现，也不是他们为ranges选择的方法。我是这么理解的。
But again, because I don't understand the technical details for why the diagnostics are worse with this implementation of concepts, it's hard for me to say that definitively. I do think that this is a, so in this particular case of calling sort, sort is an overload set.
但话说回来，因为我不理解为什么采用这种概念实现的诊断信息会更糟的技术细节，所以我很难绝对地说这就是原因。我的确认为，这是一个……所以在调用sort这个特定情况下，sort是一个重载集。
So you have a bit of extra noise here because there's some overloads take, there's an overload of sort that takes two arguments, one of which is a comparator. And there's overloads of stood ranges sort that take iterators. And the compiler sort of has to include those other overloads in the diagnostic because maybe the mistake that you made was that you'd left out an argument. In fact, my AI-assisted software engineering talk, one of the bugs that I have the AI tool try to identify for me from a cryptic diagnostic is one where I omitted a third iterator parameter
所以这里会有一些额外的噪音，因为有些重载接受……有一个接受两个参数的sort重载，其中一个是比较器。还有接受迭代器的std::ranges::sort重载。编译器在诊断信息中必须包含那些其他的重载，因为你犯的错误可能漏掉了一个参数。事实上，在我的“AI辅助软件 engineering”演讲中，有一个bug我让AI工具尝试从晦涩的诊断信息中帮我识别，那个bug就是我在调用transform时漏掉了第三个本应填进去的迭代器参数。所以它不能只是简单地假设，哦，你是想调用那个约束失败的重载。我应该只向你展示那个重载的诊断信息。因为事实可能并非如此。可能你的错误是，哦，你是想调用那个接受两个迭代器的版本。而你的参数不满足随机访问范围的原因是，它根本不是一个随机访问范围，而是一个随机访问迭代器，而你刚刚忘了提供第二个参数。正因如此，这里会有很多额外的噪音。这在某种程度上可以说是该模型固有的一些问题。当然还有
to a call to transform that I should have put in there. So it's not like it can just assume that, oh, you meant to call this overload that the constraint failed for. I should only show you diagnostics for that one. Because that may not be the case. It may be that your mistake was, oh, you meant to call the version that took two iterators. And the reason that your argument doesn't satisfy random access range is because it's not a random access range, it's a random access iterator. And you just forgot to provide the second one. And so, because of that, like there's a lot of extra noise here. And that is kind of a little bit inherent to the model. There are certainly
一些情况下，你使用的函数或事物没有像许多标准算法那样复杂的重载集……在那些情况下，我的意思是，我认为你会得到好得多的诊断信息，因为你调用了这个东西，只有一个候选重载并且它失败了，因为它由于约束失败而不匹配，它有望给你一个相当不错的解释，说明原因是什么。但你知道，重载决议（overload resolution）是个……是个好玩的东西。是的，按某种对“好玩”的定义来说，确实如此。是的，这东西太糟糕了，简直太糟糕了。是啊，是啊。我的总结就是，我们之前被承诺过，情况会比现在好得多，特别是考虑到这是概念被大力宣传的重大优势之一。那就是你可以使用那个名字而不是operator minus，你会说，哦，随机访问与双向。
some cases where you have a function or a thing that doesn't have as complex an overload set as a lot of the standard algorithms um and in those cases um i mean i think you are going to get a much nicer diagnostic because you call the thing there's only one overload candidate and it failed it doesn't match because of constraint failure it'll hopefully give you a pretty good explanation of why but you know overload resolution is uh is fun yeah for some definition of fun yeah it's awful awful stuff yeah yeah i mean the summary is just that we were kind of promised that this story would be much better than it is right now, especially given this is a major like advertised benefits of concepts. Is that you would have that name in play instead of operator minus, you would say like, oh, random access versus bidirectional.
这就是我所缺失的。是的。所以我仍然不完全理解——这远在我加入委员会之前——最初的概念特性是如何被抛弃的。但它绝对有很多方面我真的比我们最终得到的版本更喜欢，包括概念映射（concept maps）。如果人们不知道那是什么，它基本上就像是Rust的trait，非常类似于Rust的trait，在那里你可以说这个东西符合这个概念，这里有一些胶水代码让它工作。这是一个超级棒的语言特性。
That's what I'm missing. Yeah. And so I still don't understand exactly how this is way before my tenure on the committee. I don't understand exactly how the original concept stuff got uh the boot but there's definitely lots of aspects of it that i really like better than what we got including like concept maps which are um if people don't know what that is it's basically like a rust rust trait it's very similar to rust trait where you say like this thing conforms to this concept and here's some glue code that makes it work which is a super nice uh language feature.
如果你用过Rust的trait，你就知道我在说什么。它们真的非常非常方便。所以我们从最终获得的东西中失去了很多诸如此类的东西。而且我认为，对表达式进行匹配通常不如对原型（archetypes）进行匹配那么好，而这正是我们旧实现所拥有的。所以你基本上会写出：这个类型应该长成这样。然后如果它长得不像那样，那就很容易说，哦，这个东西缺少这个精确的函数重载，因为你写了那个函数重载。写出这样的代码非常容易。就像你没有这个，对吧？然而，如果没有某个
If you've used Rust traits, you know what I'm talking about. They're really, really handy. So there's a bunch of things like that that we were missing from the thing that we got. And I think matching on expressions in general is not as nice as matching on archetypes, which is what we had with the old implementation. So you would basically write out like this is how this type should look. And then if it didn't look like that, it's pretty easy to say like, oh, well, this thing is missing like this exact function overload because you wrote that function overload. It's really easy to write that. Like you didn't have this, right? Whereas if it doesn't have some
表达式，你就会想，好吧，它没有任何可以当作这个表达式来工作的代码，但这些表达式本质上是模棱两可的，对吧？例如，对于我试图匹配的类型的某个值来说，星号X（*X）——比如星号X，这是否意味着它是……我能否区分出一种仅限右值（rvalue）或仅限左值（lvalue）的、带有ref限定符的operator star？我无法区分这两者，对吧？而如果在原型中，我可以明确指出：它必须具有仅左值的ref限定符，或者const左值、右值或诸如此类的东西。我可以显式地把它写出来，或者我可以说明它必须具备其中两个，对吧？但不能三个都有，诸如此类。然后我可以指出：哦，你的类型不具备我需要的精确要求。让我为你写一份诊断信息，因为这就像常规的重载决议一样。就像我找不到与你所
expression, you're like, well, it didn't have anything that works as this expression, but those expressions are inherently ambiguous, right? Like does star X for some value of my type that I'm trying to match, like star X, like does that mean that it is – like can I draw the distinction between like an operator star that is like ref qualified for only R values or only L values, right? I can't distinguish those two, right? Whereas I could say in an archetype, like it has to have the ref qualification L value only or const L value or R value or whatever the thing is. I can write it out explicitly or I can say it has to have two of them, right? But not all three, something like this, right? And then I can say like, oh, your type doesn't have the exact requirements I need. And let me write you a diagnostic because it's just like regular overload resolutions. Like I couldn't find overload that matches this thing that you
需要的这个东西相匹配的重载一样。所以编写这样的诊断信息非常容易。我们为任何常规函数调用编写诊断信息一直都是这样做的。你知道，我真的很想在语言中拥有的特性之一就是类型擦除（type erasure）。我认为那会非常酷。但以我们现在拥有的概念特性，真的没有办法写出它，因为你希望能够说：你知道，为某个概念名称制作一个类型擦除的版本，对吧？但没有办法做到这一点，因为如果你有一些表达式，你不知道如何从该表达式回溯以合成具有精确签名的精确函数，因为有多个东西可以映射到那个表达式上，所以你知道，这在很多方面都是有问题的。我是其中
need. And so it's really easy to write diagnostics like that. That's how we write diagnostics all the time for any regular function call. You know, one of the things I really like to have is like type erasure in the language. I think that'd be really cool. But there's really no way to write it with concepts the way we have them right now because you'd like to say like you know make me a a type erased version of some concept name right but there's not a way to do it because then if you have some expression you don't know how to go back from that expression to synthesize like an exact function with an exact signature because there's multiple things that can map onto that expression so you know it's problematic in a lot of ways. And I was one of
极少数人之一，当时就觉得：“是的，我不喜欢这个新的概念构想。我认为我们不应该将其实施标准化。”我们当时有一小群人对此持怀疑态度。我不认为我们完全百分之百正确，但我认为我们确实抓住了某些要点——旧的方法确实有其可取之处。同样，我并不理解所有的技术细节，所以最初的概念方案中可能存在一些我不知道的彻底的交易破坏者（deal breaker）。
the few people that was like, yeah, I don't like this new concept formulation. I think we should not standardize this. And there was a small group of us that were like skeptical. And I don't think we were 100% correct but I think we're on to something that like the old thing had some merit. And again, I don't understand all the technical details so there could be some like complete deal breaker from the original concepts thing that I'm not aware of.
但绝对地，从用户角度来看——也就是用这两种方式编写代码会是什么感觉——我绝对更倾向于旧的模型。我觉得概念所宣称的好处并没有以C++20之前、C++20发布之前所宣传的那种方式实现。我也发现，在旧的模型中表达概念，要比在当前的模型中更容易，
But I definitely like as a user facing like what it would be like to write code both ways, I definitely prefer the old model. I feel that the purported benefits of concepts have not materialized in the way that they were advertised pre-C++20, pre the release of C++20. I also just found it easier to express concepts in the older model than in the current model
在当前模型中，你基本上需要编写使用模式。在旧模型中表达概念比在当前模型中——也就是基本上需要编写像使用模式这样的东西——要容易得多。我发现这一点非常……对我来说很不直观。是的，是的，我也这么觉得。是的，我们应该……我们应该找个时间请个人来聊聊过去的旧历史。我们应该请Doug Gregor来吗？我的意思是，他就是最合适的人选。是的，那会很棒。是谁……我想是你在波士顿告诉我去找Doug的，他在那个……PLDI 2020，对，当时我们都在那儿。是的，当时我们都在那儿。不过伙计，那可不是2020年，因为我在努力回忆那是什么时候。总之，我想那是疫情之后，所谓的疫情后……哦，看……
where essentially you write usage patterns. express concepts in the older model than in this the current model with the whole like where you essentially you write like usage patterns i find that very um non-intuitive to me yeah yeah i do too yeah we should we should uh we should have somebody on sometime to talk about the old history should we get doug gregor on i mean that would be the person to have yeah that would be nice who did uh i think it was you bryce that told me to talk to doug and he was at the um pldi so 2020 yeah when we were there together yeah when we were there together and it wasn't 2020 though buddy because i'm trying to remember when that was anyways it was i think it was post pandemic quote unquote post oh see um stockings just arrived come bring over a stock
袜子刚刚送到，过来拿一只袜子来，
and i want to see the stocking. Welcome to, oh, damn, shit's popping. Take a look at the stocking. So there's another reason why I would want to have Doc on the podcast, which is that when we met him and chatted with him in San Diego at PLDI 2022, I think, he made the bold claim that variadic templates was like a perfect feature. It's perfect, there are no nodes, there were no problems.
我想看看这只袜子。欢迎来到……哦，见鬼，事情开始变得精彩了。看一看这只袜子。所以，我想让Doug上播客的另一个原因，就是在圣迭戈的PLDI 2022（我想是那年）我们遇到他并和他聊天时，他曾大胆断言，可变参数模板（variadic templates）是一个完美的特性。它是完美的，没有任何瑕疵，没有任何问题。
And I just, I want to chat with him a bit about that, because I feel like parameter packs could have had some ergonomic improvements. Well, the only deficiency I had with it, I think, was that you couldn't index arbitrarily into
我只是……我想和他稍微聊聊这个，因为我觉得参数包（parameter packs）本可以在人体工程学上做一些改进。嗯，我对它唯一的微词，我想是，你无法对参数包进行任意索引。
a pack. And he had that as part of the proposal. I don't know if it was the root proposal or the proposals surrounding it. And everyone liked the feature, but everyone hated the different syntaxes that they saw. And everyone was waiting for better syntax to emerge, and then it never
而他曾把这一点作为提案的一部分。我不知道那是最初的提案还是围绕它的提案。每个人都喜欢这个特性，但每个人都讨厌他们看到的各种不同语法。每个人都在等待更好的语法出现，但它却从未
happened. So like they, they acknowledged at the beginning that this was like something that people wanted to do and it was very valuable, but they just couldn't come up with a syntax people liked. So much. So, so all of my years of painfully having to write all of the little quirky patterns is because of that.
发生。所以他们……他们从一开始就承认这是人们想做的事情而且非常有价值，但他们就是想不出人们喜欢的语法。太……所以，我多年来痛苦地不得不写所有那些古怪模式的原因，正是因为这个。
Yeah. Like having to tease out like the front or the, you know, the suffix or prefix of something around some value you're looking for in the middle, like all that painful code is not strictly necessary. The perfect is the enemy of the good. But we do have PAC indexing now. We just added it. I don't think it's in yet, is it?
是的。比如必须费力地挑出你正在寻找的中间某个值周围的前缀或后缀——所有这些痛苦的代码并非绝对必要。追求完美是优秀的敌人。不过我们现在确实有了参数包索引（pack indexing）。我们刚把它加进去。我觉得它还没合并进去吧？
Or I think it's been added to the working draft, but not in 23. Yeah, it's been added to the working draft. Not not. Yeah. Yeah. It's the working draft. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Twenty three. Twenty six. Yeah.
或者我觉得它已经被加进工作草案（working draft）里了，但不是在23标准中。对，它已经被加进工作草案了。还没有……是的，是的。它是工作草案的一部分。是的，是的，是的。23。26。是的。
We're going to get a twenty six. Yeah. And that's one of those like minor things that when I train people, I'm like, yeah, and there's all this thing you're probably never going to use it. And I'm like, I use it every day. Like I'm constantly using it and it changed my life. And but it's just a footnote for a lot of people. Well, hopefully we'll be able to get him on.
我们将会在26标准中获得它。是的。这就是那些微不足道的事情之一，当我培训别人时，我会说：“是的，这里有所有这些东西，你可能永远不会用到它。”而我会说：“我每天都在用它。我一直在用它，它改变了我的生活。”但对很多人来说，它只是一个脚注。好吧，希望我们能邀请到他上节目。
He can talk to us about some Swift stuff while he's at it. Doug, you probably don't listen, but if somebody that is close to Doug wants to send them this episode, it's a holiday special. So, you know, I'm sure that this will get back to Doug somehow. So Bryce, you may be curious to hear this this so we were talking about how long it takes to do stuff in the committee and something i started working on and i think 2017 2018 something like that so it's five or six years i've been working on it is uh like um unicode support for
他在的时候可以跟我们聊聊一些Swift的事情。Doug，你可能不听，但如果有人跟Doug很熟，想把这一集发给他，这是一个节日特辑。所以，你知道的，我确信这总会传到Doug耳朵里的。所以Bryce，你可能会对这个感兴趣——我们之前在讨论在委员会里完成一件事需要花多长时间，我开始着手做的一件事——我想是在2017年或2018年左右，所以我已经做了五年或六年了——就是……C++标准库的Unicode支持，对吧？而在最近的会议上，我刚刚决定：我厌倦了做这个，我根本不在乎Unicode了，我要退出，我完全要放弃它。这是一个标准库，对吧？而在我决定放弃的那次会议上，我向大家提起了这件事。我是和这个家伙Eddie Nolan一起做的。对。
c++ standard library right and i at the last meeting i just decided i am sick of working on this i don't care where unicode that much i'm walking away from i'm just abandoning it entirely It's a standard library, right? And at the last meeting, I just decided I am sick of working on this. I don't care where Unicode that much. I'm walking away from it. I'm just abandoning it entirely. But at the same meeting when I decided that, I was mentioned to people. And I did it with this guy, Eddie Nolan. Yes.
你可能还记得他在LWG（标准库工作组）里，对吧？我们前不久一起去过剧院。我听了这事的后续。好吧，好吧。所以他接手了并继续推进，我真的很高兴它没有被完全放弃，尽管是我在放弃它。我只是觉得……有时候你会达到这样一个节点，特别是对于志愿者项目来说，你对它厌倦到极点，根本无法激起动力去完成它，所以我当时就处于那个状态。
You may remember him from the LWG, right? We went to the theater together a week or so ago. And I heard the rest of this. Okay, all right. So he is picking it up and running with it and i'm so happy that it's not going to just get abandoned completely even though i'm the one abandoning it i'm just like sometimes you reach a point where especially with a volunteer thing like you're just so sick of working on it you can't motivate yourself to do it and so i was
对，对，不过Zach，Eddie是个好人。他是个好人，我为什么要那样把他推到风口浪尖呢？作为一个大活人，你为什么非要在nerd的夜晚搞这种……嗯，有趣的是，我提到我当时……我说：“是的，我也对自己感到失望，但我真的不想再干了。”然后他说：“嗯，我可能对接手这个挺感兴趣的。”我根本没求他，我当时觉得……我几乎……我几乎觉得——我应该像恺撒请求王冠那样向凯撒询问三次。就像我应该——记住，Eddie，在你签约之前，我和你确认了三次你是否真的想做这个，因为这……这责任太重了。这有大量的工作。里面有太多的政治博弈。
at that point yeah yeah but sack sack eddie is a nice guy he's a nice why do i want to throw him under the bus like that human being why do you have to go on nerds night and like this well that's the funny thing is i mentioned that i was i was like yeah i'm i'm disappointed in myself too but i'm just not going to work on it anymore and he was like well i might be interested in picking that i did not ask him i was like i almost i almost thought like i should ask ca Caesar three times to accept the crown. Like I should – now remember, Eddie, I confirmed with you three times that you wanted to do this before you signed up because it's like – it's a lot. It's a lot of work. It's a lot of political stuff.
人们对Unicode有着非常强烈的看法，而大多数人对它一无所知。这是一个奇怪且令人头疼的组合。是的。嗯，他现在……他现在已经成了“见鬼，事情开始变得精彩了”这个梗的一部分了，所以，你知道的，现在已经没有回头路了。是的。嗯，我……我……我……我認為人们没有意识到这所付出的代价，人们决定他们只是——你知道的，他们需要休息一下，或者他们只是无法继续下去了，这并不罕见。
People have very hard opinions about Unicode and then most people don't know anything about it. That's a weird and troublesome combination. Yeah. Well, he's now, he's now a part of a damn shit's popping lore. So, you know, no turning back now. Yeah. Well, I, I, I, I think that it is, people don't realize the toll that it takes and it is not uncommon for people to decide that they, they just, you know, they got to take a break or they just can't continue with things.
而问题在于，当我们没有其他人来接手这些事情时。我认为这可以追溯到之前的问题：我们是一个由300个独立作者组成的集合，而不是一个在C++中协同工作的团队。如果我们有更多的团队文化，你就不会独自一人推动这件事了，而其他那些对Unicode有强烈看法的人，就不会只是发表他们的意见，而是会进行妥协，不仅妥协并为你贡献代码，而且在委员会中，我们经常有相互竞争的提案，我们有带着各自不同想法的人，这固然是好事。
And the problem is when we don't have other people pick things up. And I think that comes back to it before we're a collection of 300 individual authors not a team of working in c++ and in a if we had more of a team culture you wouldn't be driving this thing alone and some of these other people who have strong opinions on unicode instead of just giving their opinions, they would compromise and not only compromise and give you community code, but so often in the committee we have competing proposals and we have people bringing their different ideas, which is good.
但我希望看到一个更具协作性的环境，减少任何单个作者推动某个特定事情向前发展的压力，并且让人们越来越多地以团队形式工作。是的。我听懂了话外之音。那是Corentin的错。我明白了。委员会中在这方面最成功的群体之一，一直是
But I would like to see more of a collaborative environment where there's less pressure on any individual author to drive a certain thing forward and where people work more and more as teams. Yeah. I get the subtext. It was Corentin's fault. I understand. One of the groups that's been most successful at doing this on the committee has been the
来自美国HPC（高性能计算）社区的代表团，特别是来自美国国家实验室的代表团，目前大约有六个或者我想可能是七个参与了委员会的工作。通常你会发现，他们的论文有着长长的作者名单。有时作者名单会随时间改变，因为有时如果有一件事——他们聚在一起讨论。如果这是整个社区的优先事项，你知道的，他们会找到能够推动它的人。如果某人不再有时间从事这项工作，那么其他人就可以顺理成章地接手。这种团队心态正是
contingent from the US HPC community, in particular from the US National Labs, of which there are about six or I think maybe seven now that participate on the committee. And oftentimes you'll see that their papers have a deep author list. And sometimes the author list will change over time because sometimes if there's one thing like they get together, they talk. And if there's something that is a priority for the community at whole, you know, they find somebody who can drive it. And if somebody no longer has the time to work on it, then somebody else can sort of come and pick it up. And that sort of team mindset is one of the reasons
为什么我们最近在委员会的科学和HPC领域取得了这么多成功的原因之一。是的，我真的对同样的事情印象深刻，我看到他们都在朝着（你知道的）同一个目标努力。没有人背道而驰。他们的步调一致。他们有各种认为是（你知道的）最高优先级的事情。这是很自然的。但就像，在根本上，他们都在试图达到同一个底层目标，这真的很好，你知道的，这就是为什么我们能得到（你知道的）线性代数和类似多维数组的东西。所有这些东西都是由他们以及真实的具体需求驱动的。我认为这些工作真的非常非常出色。这其中也包括SIMD的东西，对吧？SIMD的东西就来自于类似的群体。
why we've had so many successful things in the scientific and HPC space in the committee recently. Yeah, I've really been impressed by that same thing, that I see them, they're all working towards, you know, the same goal. No one's across purposes. They're on the same page. They have a variety of things that think are, you know, top priority. And that's natural. But like, at base, they're like trying to reach the same underlying goal, which is really nice, you know, and like, that's why we're getting, you know, linear algebra and like multi multidimensional array stuff,. All that stuff is driven by them and real concrete needs. And I think that stuff is really, really good work. And that includes the SIMD stuff too, right? SIMD stuff came out of a similar crowd. Yeah.
委员会中一个提案的成功，很大程度上与其说取决于提案本身的价值，不如说取决于作者的品行。甚至可以说，只要你告诉我谁在参与某个提案，我几乎就能告诉你我觉得它进入标准有多大的可能性。这完全取决于让人成为委员会中优秀捍卫者的品质——真正接受反馈和妥协的能力，以及完成工作的坚持不懈。就像那些懂得倾听、学习文化、了解他们所处房间的环境，然后展示他们的东西、获得反馈并真正铭记在心、当房间里的人告诉他们一些他们不想听的话时真正懂得倾听的人。这些人才是真正能够将某事推动到底的人。
So much of a proposal success on the committee has to do with the merits of the author, not the proposal. To the degree that I can almost tell you just, if you just tell me the name of who's working on a proposal, I can tell you how likely I think it is it's going to get into the standard. And it's solely from like the qualities that make somebody a good champion on the committee is really the ability to accept feedback and compromise and the persistence to do the work. And it's like the people who listen, who learn the culture, who learn sort of the environment of the rooms that they're in and then present their thing and get feedback and really take it to heart and really know how to listen when the room tells them something that they don't want to hear. Those are the folks who can really drive something
是的。是的。我完全同意。有很多人会像斗牛犬一样死死咬住某事不放，我说的不是贬义，我的意思是——他们能随机应变、做出改变，但他们想要看到它贯彻到底。是的。然后还有一些人，就像……我不知道，我觉得他们更像……呃，美国西南部的希拉毒蜥（gila monster）或者别的什么，他们会死死咬住某件事不放，而且绝对不松口，但却以一种糟糕的方式——那种认为“这是做这件事的唯一方法，我不喜欢所有这些与我想做的方式相违背的反对意见——我不在乎它们，它们
through to the end. Yeah. Yeah. I completely agree. There's a lot of people that will stick with something like a bulldog and just won't let go and and i don't mean that in a bad sense i mean like they they're rolling with the punches they're making changes but they want to see it through yeah and then there's some people that like um i don't know i think they're more like uh a gila monster or something they like they they clamp onto something and they're not going to let go but in a bad way like where they're like this is the only way to do this i don't like all these all these counter examples for the way i want to do it like i don't care about them they're
不重要，这是做这件事的唯一正确方法”的态度，根本没有妥协的余地，而这——这种作风是行不通的。我认为很大程度上——这也是NVIDIA在委员会中的哲学的一部分——我们带着目标和我们心目中的特性来到委员会，我们绝不固守某种特定的设计。就像，我认为这就是个赌注。如果你的目标是：我想看到……我想看到C++支持X。那这就是来到委员会的一个绝佳、绝佳的方法，就像是，
not important like this is the only right way to do this there there's no compromise and that's like that just doesn't fly i think it's a lot of it and this is part of like nvidia's philosophy the committee is we we come to the committee with, with goals and with features that we have in mind, we're never wed to a particular design. And like, I think that this is the bet. Like if your goal is like, I want to see, I want to see C++ support X. Like that's, that's a great, great approach to coming to the committee is like,
我会为了那个目标而努力；但如果你的目标是：我希望看到这个特定的设计进入C++，嗯，事情未必会按照那个方向发展——因为可能在探索该设计的过程中，你了解到委员会并没有就该特定设计达成共识。而且我认为，说服委员会接受“这是一个我们都同意的目标”，要比说服委员会接受“我想要这个特定的设计”容易成百上千倍。是的。是的，有几个设计元素我真的非常喜欢，
I'm going to work on that goal um but if your goal is i want to see this specific design go into c++ well that's that's not necessarily going to be how things are going to go um because it may be that in the course of exploring that design the you learn that there's there's not consensus to do that particular design on the committee. And I think it's orders of magnitude easier to sell the committee on, this is a goal that we agree on, than to sell the committee on, I want this particular design. Yeah. Yeah, there's been a few design elements that I was really fond of
而我不得不放手，这有点让人心碎。但与此同时，就像……呃，事实就是如此，对吧？我的意思是，你不能……你不能走进一个有30个人的房间说：“要么按我的规矩办，要么滚蛋。”他们会回答：“好吧，大路朝天，各走一边。”嗯，这是……你知道的，将某事标准化的过程，与为一个开源项目贡献东西的过程是完全一样的，那就是这一切都关乎你放弃控制权和所有权——是的，你一开始对这个东西拥有100%的所有权，然后你把它带给另一群你想寻求他们批准的人，你慢慢失去对它的所有权，它最终变成了一个共同拥有的东西。是的，绝对如此。这才是你最终想要的。
and I had just let go of them and it's kind of heartbreaking, but at the same time, like, uh, that's just, you know, that's just the way it is. Right. I mean, you can't, you can't go into a room of 30 people and say like, it's my way, the highway, they're going to be like, well, there's the highway. Well, it's, um, you know, the process of standardizing something, it's the same process of, of contributing something to an open source project where it is it's all about you giving up control and ownership like yeah you start off with 100 ownership of this thing and then you bring it to another group of people who you want to seek approval from and you slowly lose ownership of it and it becomes something that is communally owned yeah absolutely and that's what you want ultimately
我很难过你将不再参与……参与Unicode的工作，Zach，但只要……只要你继续参加标准库演进小组会议。当我告诉Eddie时——你知道的，我是说：我对直接从事这项工作缺乏动力，但我拥有一种可以说是无限量的……备用精力的东西，那就是谈论我做过的事情，或者我认为重要的事情。所以，你知道的，我告诉Eddie我会100%提供支持，我们之前已经有过一次两三个小时的通话，讨论了所有的细节之类的事情，所以我非常……我会在各方面支持他，所以希望……希望那会是一个成功，
i i am sad that you will not be working on uh on on unicode uh zach but as long as long as you continue coming to library of illusion when i told eddie like you know it's i have i have a lack of motivation to work on it directly but one thing that i have sort of an infinite um amount of of uh reserve energy for is like talking about things that that i've done or that um are i think are important and so you know i told eddie i'm going to be 100 available we already had like we had like a two or three hour call where we're talking about all the details and stuff so i'm very much uh going to support him and everything so hopefully hopefully that's a success,
但我不会再直接去做了。而且还有很多事情，我会想：听着，我的意思是，如果你做出了那个决定，我会写一篇论文说，我认为应该用另一种方式。但所有这些其他的事情——嘿，我虽然不完全同意其中的一些，但它现在是你的东西了。
but I won't be doing it directly anymore. And there's been a bunch of things where I'm like, look, I mean, if you made that decision, I'm going to write a paper saying, I think it should be a different way. But all these other things like, hey, I don't agree with some of them, but it's your thing now.
你想怎么做就怎么做。别让我来告诉你……事情不能那样做。那现在是你的事情了。嗯，这引出了一个我想问你的有趣问题，Zach，那就是你认为你在委员会中最大的成就是什么？以及，你认为你是如何为委员会创造价值的？我不知道。
Like you do it the way you're going to do it. Like, don't let me tell you, like it can't be done that way. That's your thing now. Well, this leads me to an interesting question to ask you, Zach, which is what do you view as your greatest successes on the committee? And like, how do you think that you add value to the committee? I don't know.
所以，你知道的，我以前和其他人有过几次类似的对话。但我的意思是，我认为冒名顶替综合征（imposter syndrome）有点像是……每个人都有。我知道我以前和其他人有过几次类似的对话，但我的意思是，我认为冒名顶替综合征有点像是……每个人都有，而那些没有的人，我觉得简直是一文不值——就像，如果你认为……如果你认为Bryce没有冒名顶替综合征，是的，好吧，看，评论本身说明了一切。但你知道我在说什么——你知道的，一定数量的谦逊，以及“我不知道我做的是不是对的”这种心态，是……你知道的，接受反馈并说“如果你没有百分之百确信”所必需的。
So this is, you know, I've had a few conversations along these lines with other people before. But I mean, I think imposter syndrome is kind of like everyone has it. know i've had a few conversations along these lines with other people before but i mean i think imposter syndrome is kind of um like everyone has it and the people that don't are kind of the people that i think are kind of worthless like like if you think if you think like rice doesn't have imposter syndrome yeah well hey look the the comment speaks for itself but but you know what i'm saying like you know like a certain amount of like humility and like i don't know if i'm doing the right thing is required to like sort of you know take feedback and and say like you know if you're 100 concerned i mean not concerned
我的意思是，不是确信……确信你做的是对的，而且没有其他正确的方法，那么我认为……那就成问题了。所以，从这个程度上讲，我认为……我的意思是，有时我会经历这样的时候，我的妻子对此非常熟悉，因为我是和她谈论这些事情的人。但当我准备去参加委员会会议时，有时会想：“我甚至为什么要参加这个？我不知道我是否应该做这个。”这要花很多旅行时间，要花很多时间。然后当我到达那里时，我又会超级兴奋能身处其中。但在去的路上，我并不总是那么兴奋去。所以我觉得面对面的交流真的很有用。我觉得这些年来我做过一堆自认为有用的小贡献，
convinced that you're like doing it the right way and there's no other right way to do it then i think um that's problematic so so to that extent, I think like, I mean, sometimes there's a thing I go through and my wife is very familiar with this because she's the one I talked to about this. But when I'm about to go to a committee meeting, sometimes like, why am I even going to this? I don't know if I should be doing this. It's like a lot of travel. It's a lot of time. And then I get there and I'm like super excited to be there. But on the way there, I'm not always excited to go. And so I think the in-person stuff is really useful. And I feel like I've had a bunch of small contributions that I think are useful over the years.
但我并不觉得有什么了不起的大事是我做出来的，然后可以大声说：“哦，看，（你知道的）就像Eric Niebler可以指出ranges一样。”（笑）还有Casey Carter，对吧？他们可以说我们做了这个，那是一个真正的成就。我真的觉得我没有什么类似的东西。不过，你知道的，这也无所谓。就像我……我不是在寻找……有什么大不了的事情能让我扬名立万什么的。我采用的方法更像是：有没有什么东西是我认为我们应该拥有、但我们现在还没有的，而我又拥有完成这件事的专业知识？如果我能填补那个空白，即“我认为它应该存在，但它目前不存在”，并且我认为我有能力去实现它，那么，这些就是我喜欢去从事的事情。
But I don't think there's any like big thing that I've done that's like, oh, look, you know, like Eric Nebel can point to ranges, right? And along with them, Casey Carter, right? They can say like we did this and that's a, that's a real achievement. I don't think I really have anything like that. But you know, that's fine also. Like I don't, I'm not like looking for like, what's the big thing that I'm gonna make my name with or something. I just like kind of the, the approach that I've taken is, is there something that I think we should have, but we don't have it. And I have the expertise to do that thing. If I, if I can fill that niche of like, I think it should exist, but it doesn't. And I think I, I have the, the wherewithal to do it. Then that, those are the kinds of things I like to work on.
看，看，你落入我的陷阱卡了，因为你……你是那群人之一——在我担任标准库演进小组主席期间，大概有5到10个人，我认为他们是……就像我称他们为常客（regulars），那些会留在房间里、积极参与评审，而且真正没有他们我们就无法完成工作的人。你当然属于我心目中的顶级常客评审员之列。其中一个原因就是，当你在房间里参与评审时，你通常非常直言不讳、深思熟虑，
See, see, you've fallen into my trap card here because you're, you're one of the people that, that there's maybe like five or 10 people that during my time as library evolution chair, that I think were the, the, like the, I would call them the regulars, the people who would be in the room who would actively participate in review and really without whom we could not do the work. And you're certainly, you're like in my top tier of, of regular reviewers. And one of the reasons for it is because when you're in the room participating in a review, you're usually quite vocal and thoughtful
并且能够提供深思熟虑的反馈。所以我不必担心——这就像是有人在阅读这个，我们在思考事情吗？你会表达你的意见。你想想像ranges这样的东西。Eric和Casey投入了那么多的工作、心血和（你知道的）他们生命中的多年时光，但如果没有……
in providing feedback. And so I don't have to worry about, it's like somebody reading this, are we thinking about things? You'll voice your opinion. You think about something like ranges. And Eric and Casey put so much work and effort and, you know, years of their lives into it, but those features would not have happened without
在提供反馈方面。所以我不必担心，这就好像有人在读这段代码一样，我们在思考各种问题吗？你会表达你的意见。你想想像ranges这样的特性。埃里克和凯西投入了大量的心血和努力，你知道的，还有他们数年的生命，但如果没有
the thoughtful review and feedback that they got from the committee. And I think that for people, it's funny that often some of the people who I view as the most valuable on the committee are the people who get the least praise and the least outward glory and who face the greatest imposter syndrome because they're like, oh, what am I doing here? I'm not, you know, I'm not Eric proposing the next big ranges or something. But yet those folks who show up regularly, who actively participate in the review, they have such a huge impact. And it's really, it's like you're a force multiplier because instead of driving one big feature, you are helping shape, you know,
委员会给出的深思熟虑的审查和反馈。而且我认为，对人们来说，有趣的是，通常我眼中委员会中最有价值的一些人，往往是那些得到最少赞扬、最少表面荣耀，并且面临最大冒名顶替综合症的人，因为他们会觉得，哦，我在这里做什么？我可不是，你知道的，我不是埃里克（Eric），提出什么下一个重大范围或类似的东西。但是，那些经常出现、积极参与审查的人，他们有着巨大的影响力。这真的就像你是一个力倍增器（force multiplier），因为你不是在推动一个大功能，而是在帮助塑造，你知道的，
every big feature that comes through. Yeah. Yeah, well, I appreciate that. Thanks. So I wish I had some way to somehow turn this into an insult for Bryce to diffuse the genuineness of this moment, but I can't think of one. But so I think there's a funny thing, because you say it that way. And when I'm in the room doing this, I'm like, am I talking too much? I feel like I'm talking too much. Because I feel like when I have lots of things to say about stuff, and no one else is talking about, I'm like, am I talking too much? I feel like I'm talking too much because I feel like when I have lots of things to say about stuff and no one else is talking about it, I'm like, am I dominating the conversation? Should I shut up? And I do feel like I still jump in when I
每一个通过的大功能。是的。是的，嗯，我很感激。谢谢。所以我希望我能有什么办法把这个变成对布莱斯的侮辱，来冲淡这一刻的真诚，但我实在想不出一个。不过我觉得有一件很有趣的事，因为你这么说。当我在房间里做这件事的时候，我在想，我是不是说太多了？我觉得我好像说太多了。因为我觉得当我有很多事情要说而别人都不说话时，我在想，我是不是说太多了？我觉得我好像说太多了，因为我觉得当我有很多事情要说而别人都不说话时，我在想，我是不是在主导谈话？我是不是该闭嘴？而且我觉得当我
think I have something to add. And there's something that is a function of age, I think. I think if I was 20 years younger, I wouldn't be as vocal because a lot of times I'll say something and be like, that's not at all the way that works. I'm like i'm like oh yeah yeah that's completely stupid never mind and but but it rolls right off my back and 20 years ago i would have been like you know that night but like why did i say that you know it's just been like obsessing over it so um so that's part of it too is that even though i sometimes feel like i'm like saying too much then i just keep going if i feel like there's something i don't understand, I feel like probably someone else in the room
觉得自己有话要补充时，我还是会插话。我想这也是年龄的一种体现。我想如果我年轻二十岁，我可能就不会这么直言不讳了，因为很多时候我会说出一些话，然后心想：根本不是那么回事。我就像，哦，天哪，那太蠢了，算了吧。但这也无所谓，事情就这么过去了。而二十年前，我可能会纠结（你知道的）一整晚，心想：我为什么要那样说，你知道的，就会一直对此耿耿于怀。所以，这也是一部分原因，尽管有时我觉得自己说得太多了，但如果我觉得有些事情我不懂，只要我觉得房间里可能还有别人
does understand it too. Yeah. Well, and one of the main reasons to take a poll in a C++ committee subgroup is because it allows the people who aren't willing to verbally contribute to express their opinion. Yeah. who aren't willing to verbally contribute to express their opinion um yeah and uh you know it's oftentimes 50 or more of the room are um they they don't feel comfortable they
也懂，我就会继续说下去。是的。嗯，在C++委员会小组中进行投票的主要原因之一，就是它允许那些不愿意口头表达的人表达他们的意见。是的。那些不愿意口头表达的人表达他们的意见。嗯，是的，你知道，通常房间里有50%或更多的人是……他们觉得不自在，他们
sharing because they're feeling some imposter syndrome they're like i don't know if i you know if this question's you know relevant um uh you know maybe i'm just you know stupid i don't understand it or something like that like a lot of people feel that way um and uh it's really hard like even even in a room of like world experts in c++ it or anything really it's really hard to get people to be comfortable um uh sharing because every person's like well i'm not the world expert here it's everybody else is the world expert you know well that's what you know i've gone out of my way at different times like someone especially someone who's new to the room and they say something that's just like off base because
分享是因为他们感到了某种冒名顶替综合症，他们会想，我不知道我，你知道，这个问题是不是，你知道的，相关的……嗯，你知道，也许我只是，你知道，很蠢，我听不懂或者类似的事情。很多人都有这种感觉，嗯，而且这真的很难，就像即使在一个全都是C++世界级专家的房间里，或者任何事情上，要让大家感到舒适真的是非常困难，嗯……分享，因为每个人都觉得自己“嗯，我在这里不是世界专家，所有人都是世界专家”。你知道，这就是为什么我有时会特意去说，尤其是当有新人来到房间里，并且他们说了一些完全不着边际的话，因为
they didn't they didn't understand something they lost the thread of the conversation i've gone out of my way to say like hey you know like my phrase for this is like uh ignorance is a default state of being like, you didn't know that. But that's fine. None of us were born knowing this stuff. That's like, I say, I say the wrong thing all the time, right? And I will say, I will add that to it. So I feel like, you know, we can do a good job of being really inclusive of people who are newer or just more reticent to speak out, even if they're like a regular, there's some people that show up every meeting, but they almost never say anything. And like you said, I think they're an important part of the process
他们没有……他们不理解某些东西，他们跟不上对话的思路。我会特意去说：“嘿，你知道的——我对这个的表述是：‘无知是存在的默认状态’。你当时不知道，但没关系，我们都不是生来就知道这些东西的。”这就是，我会说，我一直在说错话，对吧？我还会把这补充进去。所以我觉得，你知道的，我们可以很好地包容那些新来的人，或者只是比较寡言少语的人，哪怕他们是常客——有些人每次会议都出席，但几乎从不发言。就像你说的，我认为他们是这个过程的重要组成部分，
for the exact reason you just said. Anything that we can do as a group to help people get over that, I think is a good thing. Yeah. I mean, anybody who's spent any amount of time in meetings with me knows this. I am constantly confused. And I am completely shameless. any amount of time in meetings with me knows this i am constantly confused and i have i i am completely shameless um like i i you know if there's something i don't understand i will say
正是因为你刚才说的那个原因。作为团队，我们能做的任何帮助人们克服这种心理的事情，我认为都是件好事。是的。我的意思是，任何花时间跟我开过会的人都知道这一点。我经常感到困惑。而且我完全不知羞耻。任何花时间跟我开过会的人都知道这一点，我经常感到困惑，并且我有……我完全不知羞耻。嗯，就像我……你知道，如果有什么我不理解的，我会说
i don't understand it and i'll say like explain it to me and you know like often that is a recurring pattern in my meetings at work where i'll be like no no you're like you need to show me an example like I cannot my mind does not work this way and I can't I can't uh I can't count the number of times that I have with great confidence said a thing at a committee meeting while sharing that was like just like a total misunderstanding I was totally wrong and somebody corrected me and I'm like okay well now I okay you were right i was completely wrong um yeah and i think that's that's my superpower is just that like i'm shameless like i have i have no qualms about uh appearing and being right because it's it's the only way for me to reach understanding is if i tell people like okay, okay, like, I don't get this. Yeah, I mean, you're now like where I am now, but when I was like, you know, your age,
我不理解，我会说“请给我解释一下”。你知道，这在我的工作会议中经常发生，我会说：“不，不，你得给我看个例子，我实在……我的脑子不是这样运作的，我无法……我无法数清有多少次，我在委员会会议上自信满满地说了一番话，结果完全是个误解，我完全错了，然后有人纠正了我，我说：‘好吧，现在我明白了，你是对的，我完全错了。’是的，我觉得这就是我的超能力，就是我不知羞耻，我对于显得无知或表现正确没有任何心理负担，因为对我来说，只有当我告诉大家‘好吧，好吧，我不明白这个’时，我才能真正理解。”是的，我的意思是，你现在就像我现在的状态，但当我像……你知道的，你那么大时，
I'm not sure exactly how far apart we are in age, but I was not able to do that. I think if it keeps going like this, you're going to say some truly inappropriate things when you get to be able to, like some really like, oof, can we keep this guy in the payroll after saying that? I think that may be true. So do you do a lot of code reviews at work too?
我不确定我们确切差了多少岁，但我当时做不到这一点。我觉得如果照这样发展下去，等你到我这个年纪时，你会说出一些真正不合适的话，比如一些非常……呃，我们能在说了这些话之后还把这家伙留在工资名单上吗？我想这可能是真的。所以你在工作里也做很多代码审查吗？
Yeah, so we have a really tiny team. There used to be a larger team for just a variety of accidental reasons. We have a small team. So the three of us, we code review basically everything together. So like anytime someone pushes a major thing from their local working repo to the GitHub, we always review it. Yeah, so that's like part of the culture here, within my team anyway. Yeah, I mean, how much overlap do you think there is
对，我们有一个非常小的团队。由于各种偶然原因，以前曾有一个更大的团队。我们现在团队很小。所以我们三个人基本上一起审查所有的代码。因此，每当有人将主要内容从他们的本地工作仓库推送到GitHub时，我们总是会进行审查。是的，所以这已经是这里的文化的一部分了，至少在我团队里是这样。是的，我的意思是，你觉得代码审查和委员会审查过程之间有多少重叠？
between like the code review and the committee review process? I imagine there's a good bet. I think, I mean, I think there's a fair amount, except that it's so concrete with a code review that I think it differs that way. There's less philosophical, like, well, what are the follow-on, what are
我猜应该挺多的。我想，我的意思是，有相当多的重叠，只不过代码审查非常具体，我觉得它在这方面有所不同。它的哲学性较少，比如说，这带来的后续影响、
the knock-on effects of this going to be down the road? I mean, there's definitely some of that. You see something, you're like, oof, this is going to be hard to maintain later, and you make a comment about it. But I work with pretty conscientious people, and we don't really see code like that that much. Whereas there could be things in a proposal where you're like i see what you're trying to do but i think this interface has these potential pitfalls and another comparable interface wouldn't
未来的连锁反应会是什么？我的意思是，肯定也有一些这样的成分。你看到某些东西，就会想：呃，这以后很难维护，然后你就会对此发表评论。但我合作的人都相当有责任心，我们其实不常看到那种代码。然而，在提案中可能会有些情况，你会觉得我明白你想做什么，但我觉得这个接口有这些潜在的缺陷，而另一个同类接口则没有，
and so let's talk about that so i think that the the style of review the kind of things i'm looking for are very different i'm looking for like factual errors in the code when i'm looking at code review at work whereas i'm looking for more philosophical like there is no ground truth but could we do better in uh in committee stuff so it is different but i don't think it's fundamentally different but what about like design reviews at work or like architectural decision making like do you do any of like that that sort of stuff and is that how similar is that well so we do that and that's that's a good point but we don't so we do that and that's a good point,
所以我们来谈谈这个。所以我觉得审查的风格、我寻找的东西是非常不同的。在工作中做代码审查时，我寻找的是代码中的事实错误，而在委员会的事情中，我寻找的是更具哲学性的东西——虽然没有绝对的客观真理，但我们在委员会的事物中能不能做得更好？所以它们是不同的，但我不认为它们有根本的不同。不过，工作中的设计审查或架构决策呢？你们会做这种类型的事情吗？这有多大相似性？嗯，我们确实这样做，这是一个好点子，但是我们不……我们这样做，这是一个好点子，
but we don't, when we do that, that's not a code review. Usually we're having meetings and we're coming up with like a rough sketch of like, this is how we think things should go. And then we review kind of on the fly. So like, for instance, recently we implemented this GQL data model. And for people who don't know what GQL is, I was learning about it myself. GQL is this format for having a data model that can be easily back-ended with like a database or like you can read from a flat file or whatever. And you can always change the back-end later on and the front-end GQL data model stays the same. So people usually use GQL in like web technology and other things like this, where you run like all the data formats essentially are JSON I think by default so so we had to come up with like a front
但我们不会……当我们这样做的时候，那不是代码审查。通常我们会开会，然后拿出一个大致的草图，比如：“这就是我们认为事情应该发展的方向。”然后我们在运行中进行审查。例如，最近我们实现了这个GQL数据模型。对于不知道GQL是什么的人，我当时也是自己了解的。GQL是一种数据模型格式，可以非常容易地通过数据库作为后端，或者你可以从平面文件读取等等。而且你以后随时可以更改后端，而前端的GQL数据模型保持不变。所以人们通常在网络技术和其他类似的事情中使用GQL，在这些事情中，你运行的所有数据格式基本上默认都是JSON，我想。所以我们必须想出一个前端
end for the data model like what do the data look like how do the queries look that was amenable to an efficient implementation on the back end but there were multiple kinds of searches and queries of data you wanted to do and so we had had to have that discussion about what do the data need to look like at the API level so that we can write all these efficient backends and then have room to change them out with other backends later on if we decide to do that. So that's the kind of big architectural thing where you have questions like, does this limit us in the future? What are the tradeoffs? That kind of thing. So that kind of thing is very much like the same kind of review we do in the committee. But that just tends not to be a code review. So we have this culture of code reviews in the form of PRs, but then
针对数据模型的设计——数据看起来是什么样的？查询看起来是什么样的？这要有利于在后端进行高效实现。但由于你想对数据进行多种类型的搜索和查询，因此我们必须讨论数据在API级别上需要是什么样的，以便我们能够编写所有这些高效的后端，并留出空间在以后决定这样做时将其替换为其他后端。所以这就是那种大型架构方面的事情，你会面临这样的问题：这会限制我们未来的发展吗？权衡是什么？诸如此类。因此，这种事情非常类似于我们在委员会中进行的同类审查。但这往往不是代码审查。所以我们有PR形式的代码审查文化，但
the big architectural stuff tends not to be like that. It tends to be more of a design meeting kind of thing. Wait, would you have any advice to people that are seeking to become better reviewers of in any shape? Like what's your what's your secret? Well, I think so. This is a question that I heard someone at C++ Now ask Eric Niebler when I was right there. And I've had part of the answer that I gave myself. But the question was, how do I become a good library writer like you know and this is something I've actually specialized in my career I'm like like I'm a library person like first and foremost and but that's that's a rare thing like people
大型架构方面的事情往往不是那样的。它往往更像是一种设计会议。等等，对于那些想要在任何方面都成为更好的审查者的人，你有什么建议吗？你的秘诀是什么？嗯，我想是的。这是我在C++ Now大会上听到有人问埃里克·尼布勒（Eric Niebler）的一个问题，当时我就在旁边。我也有自己的一部分答案。但当时的问题是：“我如何才能像你一样成为一个优秀的库编写者？”你知道的，这其实是我职业生涯中专注的领域，我就像……我首先是一个库领域的人，但这是一种罕见的事情，人们
don't usually specialize in libraries for whatever reason and Eric said something somewhat similar to this, but my take on that answer is read lots of library code and do things along the lines of, like, when I sit down to write a library, the first thing I want to do is write, like, the use of the library, not any code or design or anything like notes about how the library should work. So the idea is, as a user of the library, I want my code to look like this nice, beautiful thing that is, you know, the ideal. And then maybe when you're implementing the library, you can't quite get there for some technical reason you can't have that interface that you started with but maybe you can find another way to have like a very graceful kind of thing to work with so i think essentially a good review of high-level design and a good design of a library are isomorphic in that you want lots of things to be the same about them right like if it's possible to do so you want to make it impossible to use it incorrectly if that's not possible to make it difficult to use incorrectly you want to not violate the principle of the surprise when you return something it
通常不会无缘无故地专门从事库开发。埃里克说了一些类似的话，但我对那个答案的理解是：阅读大量的库代码，做一些类似的事情——比如，当我坐下来编写一个库时，我要做的第一件事就是编写这个库的使用示例，而不是任何代码、设计或类似的东西，而是关于这个库应该如何工作的笔记。所以这个想法是，作为这个库的用户，我希望我的代码看起来像这个漂亮、完美、理想的东西。然后也许当你实现这个库时，由于某些你无法拥有最初那样的接口的技术原因，你可能无法完全做到这一点，但也许你可以找到另一种方式，来实现一个非常优雅的操作方式。所以我认为，本质上，对高级设计的好坏审查与一个库的好坏设计是同构的，即你希望它们有很多相同之处，对吧？如果可能的话，你要做到让人不可能错误使用它；如果不可能，也要做到让人很难错误使用它。你希望在返回某些东西时不要违反最小惊奇原则，
should be the kind of thing you would expect from a function with that name to return blah blah blah there's a bunch of them that people are familiar with. And so the way you get there, I think, is iteration, right? You design interfaces or high-level things, and then you see how it works, and then you just do it and do it and do it, and eventually you develop good taste, right? I feel like I have good taste now, and I feel like I started with awful taste, and I had to sort of get there by making mistakes over and over again. So I really think it's a question of doing it and then seeing what works and seeing what doesn't. And you can short circuit some of that doing it yourself by just reading other people's APIs and large level architecture things and understanding why they work and what the trends are. And then more examples is another way of getting reps. I definitely feel like I've learned a lot about what good design looks like from witnessing bad design or doing bad design and then spending years paying the consequences of the bad design.
它应该符合你对具有该名称的函数的预期返回值，诸如此类，有很多大家都很熟悉的原则。所以我觉得实现这一目标的方法是通过迭代，对吧？你设计接口或高级事物，然后看它如何运作，接着不断地做、不断地做、不断地做，最终你就会培养出良好的品味，对吧？我觉得我现在有了好的品味，而我觉得我刚开始时的品味简直糟透了，我不得不通过一次又一次地犯错来达到现在的境界。所以，我真的认为这是一个通过实践去发现什么可行、什么不可行的问题。你可以通过直接阅读别人的API和大型架构并理解它们为什么有效以及有哪些趋势，来走一些亲自动手的捷径。此外，通过接触更多例子来积累经验是另一种途径。我绝对觉得，通过亲眼目睹糟糕的设计，或者自己做出糟糕的设计，然后花上数年时间去承担糟糕设计带来的后果，我学到了很多关于优秀设计到底是什么样的知识。
Yes. Yeah. And I think, you know, there's I have what I consider to be a superpower, which is that when I hear good advice, I recognize as good advice the first time I hear it a large percentage of the time. And what I've discovered is that that's just not what other people are doing. Like, I didn't realize this was a superpower until I got experienced enough to see people getting very good advice and ignoring it before I realized, like, oh, this is like a thing that I'm particularly good at. I had no idea it was a thing to be good at. But so like when someone says when you do it like this, this is the problem, we do it like that, this is the other problem, that's really good advice. That is hard won knowledge that someone with the experience you just described where they did it and they had to live with the consequences of it. And when you hear that, you should internalize that as if you did it yourself
是的。是的。而且我认为，你知道的，我有一个被我自己认为是超能力的东西，那就是当我听到好的建议时，在很大比例的情况下，我第一次听到它就能识别出它是好建议。而我发现的是，其他人并不是这样的。比如，直到我有了足够的经验，看到别人得到很好的建议却置之不理，我才意识到——哦，原来这是我特别擅长的一件事。我以前根本不知道这是一件可以擅长的事。所以，当有人说“当你这样做时，问题就在于此；我们如果那样做，就会遇到另一个问题”，这真的是很好的建议。那是来之不易的知识，来自于有着你刚才描述的那种经历的人——他们亲身实践过，不得不与这些后果共存。当你听到这个时，你应该将其内化，就好像那是你亲身经历的一样，
to the extent that you're able to do that. I think that's a big part of the process. Because if you pay for every mistake you make, that's great and you'll learn that way, but you should try to short-circuit that to the extent you can. Yeah. Hey, that's enough, babe. I'm sorry, but I mean, I was just answering what you asked me I don't think you should call me babe it was inappropriate
只要你有能力做到这一点。我认为这是整个过程的重要组成部分。因为如果你为自己犯下的每一个错误买单，那很好，你也会从中学到东西，但你应该在力所能及的范围内尽量走捷径。是的。嘿，够了，宝贝。对不起，但我的意思是，我只是在回答你的问题。我觉得你不应该叫我宝贝，这很不合适。
I somebody said this to me earlier in my career that like the mark of a really smart person is the speed with which they change their opinion when convinced that they were wrong. That like somebody who's like a really, really, really smart person,
我早年职业生涯中有人跟我说过这样一句话：一个真正聪明的人的标志，在于当他们被说服自己错了时，改变观点的速度有多快。就像一个真正、真正、真正聪明的人，
like you show them in some way that they were wrong and then just like, boom, like 180. They're like in the completely opposite direction. Yeah. Well, I think that's true, but I think there's also some maturity that comes into play there too because like if you're just like really like self-conscious and kind of a raw nerve all the time, some people just double down on something when they know it's wrong because they just can't stand to be wrong. Do you know what I mean? Yeah.
你用某种方式向他们证明他们错了，然后他们就会像——轰的一下，来个180度大转弯。他们就像走向了完全相反的方向。是的。嗯，我觉得这确实如此，但我也觉得其中包含了一些成熟度，因为如果你总是非常自我意识过剩、像一根时刻紧绷的神经，有些人明明知道自己错了，却偏要一条道走到黑，因为他们根本无法忍受自己是错的。你知道我的意思吗？是的。
They see what you're saying and they refuse to acknowledge it because they – so there has there has to be some temperament in there too but i think that's generally true like um you've uh maybe read thinking fast and slow this danny kahneman book it's a fantastic book oh it's so good i have basically sorry you have or have not connor i have yeah i'm a big uh behavioral economics you know pop science fan yeah me too i really love it so this is a book that about every uh 10 to 15 pages, I was like, oh, that's why my brain works that way. I mean, it's really like a user manual for your head. It's really great. But it's based on work done by one of the author, who was Danny Kahneman and his partner in crime, this guy named Amos Tversky. And Danny Kahneman
他们明白你的意思，但就是拒绝承认——所以这其中也必须具备某种性格气质，但我认为这通常是真的。比如，你可能读过丹尼尔·卡尼曼（Danny Kahneman）写的《思考，快与慢》（Thinking, Fast and Slow），那是一本极好的书。哦，太棒了！我基本上——抱歉，卡纳（Connor），你看过还是没看过？我看过，是的。我是个狂热的、行为经济学（你知道的）大众科学粉丝。是的，我也是，我真的很喜欢。所以这是一本大约每10到15页就会让我觉得“哦，原来我的大脑是那样运作的”的书。我的意思是，它真的是你头脑的使用手册，真的很棒。但它基于该书作者之一的工作，也就是丹尼尔·卡尼曼和他的黄金搭档阿莫斯·特沃斯基（Amos Tversky）。丹尼尔·卡尼曼
writes, not in Thinking Fast and Slow, but in another book about their collaboration, he writes this thing that amongst people that knew Amos Tversky, there was this agreement that the best IQ test in the world was how long it took you to realize Amos Tversky was smarter than you. And if you just got it immediately, you were amongst the brightest. And Amos Tversky was above you but but you knew where you were um and i think uh i think that's really fascinating that there's there's something like similar about that you know like can you can you recognize your own failings and how quickly yeah yeah i definitely feel like that's something that i'm i'm pretty good at. Although, I don't know. I still retain stubbornness at some points. Yeah, yeah.
写道——不是在《思考，快与慢》里，而是在另一本关于他们合作的书里——他写了这样一件事：在认识阿莫斯·特沃斯基的人当中，大家达成了一种共识，即世界上最好的智商测试，就是你需要花多长时间才能意识到阿莫斯·特沃斯基比你聪明。如果你立刻就明白了，那你就是最聪明的人之一。而阿莫斯·特沃斯基在你之上，但你知道自己的位置。嗯，我觉得这真的非常迷人，（你知道的）有些类似的事情，比如——你能否认识到自己的缺点，以及速度有多快？是的，是的，我绝对觉得这是我挺擅长的一件事。尽管，我不知道，我在某些方面仍然保留着固执。是的，是的。
We probably should start wrapping up because I got to prepare for the arrival of the Polish relatives. And I do need to board my flight in like 10 minutes. Wait, Connor. Wait, wait, wait. Boarding starts in 10 minutes or my flight in like 10 minutes. Wait, Connor. Wait, wait, wait. Boarding starts in 10 minutes or the plane leaves in 10 minutes? No, no. Boarding officially starts in 17 minutes at 12.05 Pacific time. So I do have to get to the gate, though, which is on the other side of the airport, which is why.
我们大概应该开始收尾了，因为我得准备迎接波兰亲戚的到来。我确实需要在大概10分钟内登机。等等，卡纳。等等，等等，等等。是10分钟后开始登机，还是我的航班在10分钟后起飞？等等，卡纳。等等，等等，等等。是10分钟后开始登机，还是飞机在10分钟后起飞？不，不。登机手续官方上在17分钟后开始，也就是太平洋时间12点05分。不过我确实得去登机口，登机口在机场的另一头，这就是为什么……
You fly in Air Canada, home? And I think actually at one point I was going to mention which we can mention it now is that yes i'm in san diego you're in austin uh zach and then bryce is in new york so we're coast to coast uh yeah probably the first first time it's an a220 300 you want the tail number? Jesus Christ. Oh, Bryce. I really hope that the audio is going to be fine, because if you didn't record locally for the first bit, that means we're going to have to use the audio from this meeting. You were muted for pretty much that whole time.
你坐加拿大航空回家吗？我想其实我之前本来要提一件事，我们现在可以提了，那就是——是的，我在圣迭戈，你在奥斯汀，扎克，然后布莱斯在纽约，所以我们是跨大陆的。是的，可能这是第一次……是一架A220-300，你想知道尾号吗？天哪。哦，布莱斯。我真的很希望音频能没问题，因为如果你刚才有一段时间没有在本地录音，那就意味着我们不得不使用这次会议的音频。你刚才几乎全程都是静音状态。
Not at the beginning, though. So anyway, hopefully it'll be fine. And this is the holiday gift to the listeners that I'm pretty sure we're just going to release this all in one go. So this is going to set the record for the longest episode by a long shot. And of course, now I've dropped from the meeting again, but I think Bryce and Zach can probably still hear what I'm saying. Anyways, this has been absolutely amazing. High-low, rust, bleeding-edge C++, elements of programming, committee stuff. You know, the listener is going to be having a very enjoyable holiday season thanks to,
不过刚开始的时候没有。所以无论如何，希望一切会好吧。这是送给听众的节日礼物，我非常确立我们打算一次性把这个全部发布出去。所以这将以巨大的优势打破最长单集纪录。当然，现在我又从会议中掉线了，但我猜布莱斯和扎克可能还能听到我在说什么。无论如何，这真的太棒了。高低速、Rust、前沿的C++、编程元素、委员会事务……你知道的，多亏了……听众将会度过一个非常愉快的假期，
and most importantly, ah, damn, shit's popping. I like how that just doesn't sound like it goes with hosted by Bryce and Connor. It just doesn't go together somehow. Quick, quick, end the podcast now. We shouldn't have started talking about travel. It's going to be another hour and I'm going to miss my flight. We're going to have to wrap up. This also has a much smaller demographic that's interested in hearing your guys' travel complaints.
最重要的是——啊，该死，出岔子了。我喜欢这种听起来跟“由布莱斯和卡纳主持”完全不搭的感觉。它就是莫名其妙地不搭。快，快，现在结束播客。我们本不该开始谈论旅行的。这会变成另一个小时，而我会错过我的航班。我们得收尾了。对于听你们两个人的旅行抱怨感兴趣的人群，这个节目的受众比例要小得多。
All right. Well, thank you all. It's been fun. Yeah, thanks, Zach. This was a blast. Yeah, thanks for having me. Merry Christmas. Be sure to check your show notes in your podcast app or at ADSPthepodcast.com for links to any of the topics we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a GitHub discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. If you made it this far, consider sharing with a friend or your followers on whichever social media platform you prefer, whether that's Twitter, LinkedIn, or another, as this was a lot of work to edit. But we appreciate all of our listeners and thought we'd do something special because people are constantly requesting that we don't slice and dice these up the way that we typically do. Anyways, thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great holiday season. Low quality, high quantity. That is the
好吧。谢谢大家。这很有趣。是的，谢谢扎克。这太棒了。是的，谢谢你们邀请我。圣诞快乐。请务必查看你的播客应用中的节目说明，或者访问 ADSPthepodcast.com，获取我们在今天节目中提到的任何话题的链接，以及GitHub讨论区的链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。如果你听到了这里，请考虑与朋友或你在任何社交媒体平台上偏爱的粉丝分享，无论是推特、领英还是其他平台，因为编辑这个节目需要付出大量的工作。但我们感谢所有的听众，觉得应该做一些特别的事情，因为人们经常要求我们不要像平时那样把这些内容切碎。无论如何，谢谢收听。希望你们喜欢，并祝大家节日快乐。低质量，高质量。这就是我们
tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
播客的标语。这不是标语。我们的标语是“洒满信息 sprinkles 的混乱”。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。